Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Moin.
Ich hab hier noch ein Croissant.
Das muss ich mal kurz futtern.
Aber ohne ASMR-Eating-Sounds.
Gleich wieder am Start.
Wobei, das ist gar kein echtes Croissant.
So ein Fake.
So ein Fake Lidl Croissant.
Oh Leute.
So, Croissant ist weg.
Ich sehe was entspannenderes an.
Excel.
Excellent.
Ey, F-Programmer, du merkst ja auch alles, oder?
Nur weil ich irgendwann mal erzählt hab,
dass ich immer eine Mütze auf habe.
Ich muss mich auch nicht mehr daran erinnern.
Ich habe gestern kurz vermutet,
vielleicht bist du Arbeitskolleg.
Inkognito.
Aber das passt nicht.
Ja, hab ich gelesen.
Moin, Expressiv.
Moin, der Feuder ist wieder am Start.
Nü, Twitch, wilder Igel, der Ragman.
Aber wir müssen uns unbedingt neue
Pepo Happy Hintergründe ausdenken.
Leute, ich...
Oh, Moment. Sekunde.
Bevor ich das vergesse,
gerade noch mal die Pillen einschmeißen.
Nein, keine Drogen von Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof.
Sachen, die ich nehmen muss.
So.
Alles auf einmal reingeschmissen.
Dankeschön, den Sub.
Exzellente Subscriptions.
Eigentlich, um korrekt zu sein, ist es sogar ein.
Leute, ich
hab gestern...
Manchmal mach ich den Fehler,
und scrolle zu lang auf Twitter.
Sorry, x, x formerly known as Twitter.
Manchmal scrolle ich da zu viel rum.
Ich habe gestern irgendwo
einen Comment gelesen,
was mich übelst getriggert hat.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was der Ursprungs...
Moment, erstmal muss ich mal eine Logitech...
Logitech Software starten, weil ohne korrekt
RGB beleuchtete Tastatur
verwirrt mich wenn man das so komische beleuchtung gestern gescrollt bisschen
auf twitter und wie gesagt ich weiß gar nicht mehr was der ursprungs der
ursprungs tweet war man kriegt ja teilweise übelsten schwachsinn empfohlen
und was mich was mich so ein bisschen was mich so ein bisschen getriggert hat
oder nachdenklich gemacht hat ist wobei es erzähle ich vielleicht später wenn
ein bisschen mehr Leute da sind.
Ich kenn mich, ich schwätz dann wahrscheinlich jetzt wieder eine halbe Stunde
drüber. Ich warte noch mal
kurz. Zumindest irgendeine dumme Antwort,
die aber nicht dumm
war für sich genommen, sondern
wahrscheinlich was,
das viele Leute wirklich glauben und
ich halt denke, wie kann man so blöd sein, das glauben.
So.
dann machen wir doch gerade mal wenn wir schon dabei sind aber hier den mini pc an
weil ich wollte gestern eigentlich eine runde streamen aber ich habe dann
angefangen auf stream ein bisschen rast zu programmieren und irgendwie wie
nennt man das war ich dann im rast rabbit hole und habe mir irgendwelche
unstable features angeguckt und festgestellt dass das doch ziemlich eine ziemlich unverständliche
sprache ist in manchen manchen bereichen ja also und überschneidungen mit sich im port und aber
ich habe mich da gestern durchgekämpft und das gucken wir uns dann wahrscheinlich auch im stream
an was ich da rausgekriegt habe aber da habe ich den ganzen tag rum gebastelt und dann war es
irgendwann schon 18 uhr und gut jetzt muss man einmal spielen später wird dann 19 uhr das ist
lohnt sich jetzt an mehr tunnel so dann starten wir jetzt nochmal cash ios
Agile.
Massive Top Secret Passwort.
Sieht man eigentlich das Passwort, wenn man da drauf klickt?
Ich kann ja nicht drauf klicken.
Cheap Baited.
Das ist ja Windows Cursor hier.
Kann ich ja gar nicht drauf klicken.
Lul.
HD.
XD, overrated, she baited
No signal
Warum?
Weißt du?
Auch Fake News hier
Natürlich ist ein Signal da
Fuck, dann starten wir mal hier
Eine Runde Firefox
Eine Runde Terminal
Und was ist das erste Chat, was wir machen?
wenn wir die Linux-Kiste einmal in der Woche gestartet haben?
Was kommt jetzt?
Genau.
Genau das.
Oh, ist ganz schön viel.
Halbe Internet wird runtergeladen.
Aber dann.
Let's go. Gucken wir mal, ob wir hier Updates
haben bei den Jetbrains-Dinger.
Jet-Jetbrains.
By the way, Leute.
Ich hab jetzt auf der Arbeit...
Wir haben übrigens MonkaDB
als Emote im Chat jetzt,
falls ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt.
WuppDB
haben wir jetzt. Guck mal hier.
Bam.
Und ihr werdet
feststellen,
ihr werdet feststellen,
das DB-Logo fehlt.
Das hat jemand im Discord
rausgemacht, weil ich gesagt habe, sonst könnte es vielleicht
Copyright-Probleme geben.
So, jetzt habe ich vergessen,
was ich sagen wollte. Chat, helf mir mal kurz.
Irgendwas wollte ich doch...
Ah, Mist. Jetzt hab ich sie
verpeilt. Achso, genau.
Ja, ich weiß wieder.
Das ist ein Subscriber-Emote.
Ich mein, man könnte auch
das als 7TV-Emote
machen.
Aber ich hab noch so viele Slots frei für
Subscriber-Emotes.
Arbeit, genau.
Was wollte ich denn erzählen?
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Zumindest, ich habe jetzt einen fast vollständigen, vollwertigen Linux-Arbeitsplatz auf der Arbeit.
Also ich habe immer noch das Windows-Notebook, da kommt man nicht drum herum.
Windows muss sein.
Oder alternativ, wenn das Windows-Notebook nicht tut, dann Zutrix.
Windows-Zutrix, das habe ich immer noch.
Aber ich habe eine VM mit Grafikkarte drin.
Wobei jetzt halt die Frage, ob man das braucht oder nicht.
Zumindest eine VM mit Grafikkarte drin, auf der Linux läuft und auf die ich per RDP gehe.
Nachdem es RDP ist, könnt ihr euch denken, es ist noch ein Ubuntu 2404 mit X.
Also da läuft X RDP drauf.
Aber Leute, das ist so angenehm.
Citrix, wurde das nicht durch AVD ersetzt?
Ne, das gibt es immer noch.
Hier.
Citrix.
Aber was ist AVD? Das kenne ich gar nicht.
Ach, Azure.
Azure Virtual Desktop.
Ne, ne, ne.
Wir haben immer noch selbst gehostet das Citrix.
So, und...
Ich habe jetzt im Endeffekt einfach bei mir auf...
Ich logge mich da ein.
Im Windows Notebook.
und dann starte ich ein paar
Portforwards und dann gehe ich per RDP
hier drauf. Ich mache jetzt einfach einen zweiten Windows Desktop
und dann mache ich im Fullscreen
mein Linux Desktop.
Dann gehen auch alle Shortcuts und sowas.
Und da habe ich
einen vollwertigen Linux Desktop.
Aber das ist gar nicht das, was ich erzählen wollte.
Ich habe das irgendwie ein bisschen
verpeilt, was ich
euch jetzt eigentlich sagen
wollte.
vollwertiger linux desktop keine ahnung mir fällt mir fällt es bestimmt schon wieder ein
so ist das sehr nah ist es ist endlich mal wieder nicht kann man aber gescheit arbeiten
reboot ist ein rekomendiert ob es hier updates gibt es gibt es nicht da gibt es auch nicht dann
Und dann machen wir jetzt mal Reboot.
Und da muss ich mir den Tastatur umstöpseln.
Kann ich nicht ordentlich rebooten.
Knackwing Arbeit und
deutscher Bahn.
Ey, keine Ahnung mehr.
Brain lag.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Haben wir alles ready.
Theoretisch könnte ich das auch machen,
bevor ich den Stream anmache.
Aber nachdem der Stream
eh immer ein paar Minuten braucht,
bis der richtig angelaufen ist, warum nicht?
Also ich habe das mehr oder weniger genauso auf der Arbeit hier auch.
Ich benutze allerdings XFCE als Desktop, weil über RDP relativ leichtgewichtig.
Kommt auch schon vorinstalliert.
Und ich habe es da genauso.
Erster Desktop Browser, zweiter Desktop Terminal, dritter und vierter Desktop für andere Kram.
Das ist sehr angenehm.
Und ich habe meine alte Konfig da auch rüber kopiert.
Also ich habe da einen ähnlichen Prompt.
Ich kann da Westterm drauf verwenden, allerdings Westterm ist ein bisschen laggy auf dieser VM.
Deswegen benutze ich da Terminator.
Aber hier benutze ich weiterhin Westterm.
Westterm Bessel.
Wie gesagt, sehr angenehm,
ordentlichen Linux-Desktop zu haben.
Und bei der Gelegenheit ist mir aufgefallen,
weil das ist immer ein bisschen schwierig,
wisst ihr,
also wenn man
von Windows aus
per RDP
auf eine Remote-Kiste geht.
Wisst ihr, dass es ziemlich beschissen ist,
aus dem RDP rauszukommen mit der Tastatur?
Du musst, um Windows Remote Desktop
rauszukommen, musst du
Ctrl-Alt-Post-1
auf der Tastatur drücken.
Dann kommt hier oben
diese Remote-Desktop-Leiste, wie gesagt,
das seht ihr jetzt nicht, weil das hier ist kein Remote-Desktop.
Kommt hier oben diese Remote-Desktop-Leiste
und
dann gelten die
Shortcuts wieder für das Hausbetriebssystem.
Richtig, richtig weird, Champ.
Und bei der
Gelegenheit ist mir aufgefallen, dass meine
Tastatur, die ich auf der Arbeit habe,
jetzt sogar Makros kann.
Aber
super kompliziert.
Ja, super, super kompliziert
Makros zu programmieren.
Und das sind Hardware-Makros, ja?
Also die sind quasi in der Tastatur dann drinnen.
Das ist super kompliziert,
wie man Makros aufnimmt.
Es geht halt nur mit Hotkeys,
kannst du das aufnehmen.
So nach dem Motto,
Press Function plus 2, activate.
Press Hold Fn, Control for 3 seconds.
Das ist das Makro.
Press Function plus Page up.
Also ganz, ganz wirres Zeug.
Kann man Makros recorden.
Und ich bin gerade dabei,
mir ein Makro zu recorden,
dass ich ordentlich switchen kann
zwischen Nemo Desktop und Windows.
Dass ich nicht immer
Ctrl Alt Position 1
Ctrl Alt linke Pfeiltaste drücken muss
Und sowas
Workspace, ja beste
Beste
Theoretisch, wisst ihr was auch das geile damit ist
Theoretisch
Könnt ihr hier
Den Hackermann Kram aufhaben
Und hier
Macht ihr irgendwie
Hier macht ihr
Moment
Hier macht ihr sowas
So
Und wenn dann euer Chef reinkommt, dann sagst du
Bam, ich bin gerade voll dabei hier
In the zone
Hups
Was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Ich habe es irgendwie geschafft, gerade das alles auf Lambda umzuschalten
Wie ging das, Chat?
Ah, jetzt
Chat, ich weiß nicht, wie ich das gemacht habe
Ehrlich gesagt
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass C-Matrix
irgendwelche
speziellen
Shortcuts hat.
Minus M.
Aber anscheinend
kann man das auch so.
Hier, Keystrokes.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Das ist ja noch besser.
Da kann man C-Matrix einfach anmachen
und wenn man lange noch
random auf der Tastatur rumdingst,
dann ändert sich das sogar noch.
So, auch wieder zu.
Aber was machst du mit 13 Workspaces?
13 Workspaces ist echt ordentlich.
Ah, trennt's auf GitHub auf.
Also,
Also, das Problem ist, wie steuerst du überhaupt 13 Workspaces an?
Mit Next, also mit Vor und Zurück, weil du kriegst ja auf die Tastatur oben...
Na doch, doch, du kriegst 13 Workspaces auf die Tastatur.
Guck mal, das geht, das geht.
Guck mal, erster Workspace, das Zeichen.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 0.
Fragezeichen, Dings.
Das sind doch...
Warte mal, sind das 13?
Sind das 13?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13.
Ey, das ist ja Six Head, Alter.
Deswegen 13 Workspaces, jetzt verstehe ich es.
Also quasi die obere Reihe der Tastatur komplett voll.
Ja, ich habe das nicht.
Ich benutze nur 1, 2, 3, 4.
manchmal 5, wobei 5 habe ich hier
bei KDE gar nicht eingeblendet.
Manchmal 5,
weil es ansonsten
musst du so sehr, also
du musst so sehr deine
Hand verbiegen, dass du das
hinkriegst. Wobei es gibt
ja Leute, die
machen dann, die haben hier oben
Scrolling an, ja, dass man hier durch
die Workspaces scrollen kann, so mit
der Maus.
Dann geht das auch, aber da muss ich erstmal zur Maus greifen.
Das ist auch doof.
Ähnlich ist es bei Hyper-V.
Oh, bist du in einer schmerzlichen Lage, Hyper-V verwenden zu müssen?
Übrigens eine Sache, die mich ein bisschen ärgert bei meiner neuen Linux-VM auf der Arbeit,
dass die Nested-Virtualisierung nicht eingeschaltet haben.
Sonst könnte ich den VM-Champ verwenden.
Nicht, dass ich ihn bräuchte oder so,
aber Nested-Virtualisierung ist nicht eingeschaltet.
Das heißt,
ich hänge auf Container fest.
Ja, und ich habe das hier auch schon probiert.
Das da.
Ja, auch schon probiert,
aber geht nicht, weil kein
KVM-Device vorhanden ist.
Leider. Guck.
Es ist manchmal
echt ganz praktisch.
eine
VM starten zu können.
Also das ist jetzt kein Container,
das ist wirklich eine richtig echte
VM, geht halt auch schnell zu starten,
nicht wirklich viel
langsamer als
jetzt ein Container zu starten,
natürlich ein bisschen langsamer, und das ist
halt eine vollwertige VM.
Das heißt, ich könnte hier jetzt auch,
wenn ich ein Image hätte mit SystemD
drin, SystemD verwenden,
und ich kann hier vor allem halt auch so dinge machen wie moment ich jetzt
bescheuert updates gemacht haben dass ich schmeißen gleich wieder weg
hier kannst du kannst halt modprobe minus rpc speaker oder so machen was halt sonst in
containern nicht so einfach funktioniert container funktioniert zwar auch die
musste privilege starten muss die module mountain aber das bringt ja nix ja wenn
du was testen willst im anderen kölner ist eine vm viel praktischer als ein
container ansonsten tut es container genauso
messe follow max hast du gesehen dass ich dass du versuchst hast in die
unterbau keine ahnung ich könnte machen was ihr wollt du hast keine führung
Achso, wolltest du eine Führung bei Google machen?
Also, dass es bei Google Führungen gibt, ist mir neu.
Also wir hatten letztens eine Führung bei Google in Frankfurt.
Allerdings nur weil wir Google Kunde sind und die sich von einer, von der, wie sagt man so, von der goldenen Seite, nee, von der besten Seite zeigen wollten.
Aber bei Amazon weiß ich, kann man Führungen sich irgendwie buchen.
Ja.
Rebootet habe ich schon, oder?
Ja, habe ich.
Big Brain, Low IQ gerade.
Schau mal bei Steam, da ist gerade Programming fest.
Aha.
Und was gibt's da?
Das Steam Programming Fest ist hier
Okay
Alter, Hacker Man
Das sind doch KI generierte Bilder, oder Leute?
Leute, ihr könnt mir nicht sagen, dass der Hintergrund nicht KI generiert ist
Mit diesen random sinnlos Zeichen, ja
Wenn das nicht KI generiert ist, dann war ich schon, ja
Ja gut, da gibt's, da gibt's, Leute, gibt's da Factorio?
Factorio ist
Ist ja auch ein Programming Game
Wenn man es so will, also wenn man es übertreibt
Man kann Factorio auch so normal spielen
Aber es gibt verrückte Leute
Die programmieren
In Factorio, es gibt zum Beispiel
Weiß nicht, ob ich euch das mal gesagt habe
Ähm
Factorio
Äh, Engine
Moment
ID Engine, Factorio
3d game engine in faktorio
die leute haben sie nicht wahr oder total verrückt
3d engine in faktorio
also das ist letztendlich was ihr seht das sind irgendwelche irgendwelche fliesbänder
oder so worauf er das woraus er das gebaut hat total abgedreht oder
jetzt zeigt also so was in faktor zur bauern schon heftig
Do my Factorio
Ja, oder
Guck hier, hier sieht man das was er gebaut hat
Das ist total abgedreht
Deswegen, Factorio
Factorio ist auch ein
Programming Game, wenn man es drauf anlegt
Leute, ich war gestern
gestern Abend, da hab ich ein bisschen auf Twitter
gescrollt, das ist ja mal
wie soll man sagen, etwas
kontraproduktiv
bevor man ins Bett geht
weil im Zweifelsfall scrollt man da auf
irgendwelche Dinger, die einen
aufregen oder nerven oder
Leute, wo man sich einfach an den Kopf greift und denkt
Alter, wie kann man so dumm sein
Was ich aber
auch witzig, ich muss
jetzt einfach mal loswerden
Was ich immer lustig finde, ich kriege ja auf Twitter oftmals auch irgendwelche sinnlos politische Diskussionen angezeigt von allen möglichen Seiten.
Und ich finde es witzig, wie sehr sich teilweise die Argumente von den beiden Enden des Spektrums sich ähneln.
Zum Beispiel habe ich letztens gelesen, der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk, die wären alle super krass links.
Und dann habe ich letztens einen Tweet gelesen von der anderen Seite, die haben gesagt, in den Genen des öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks liegt es, dass sie rechts sind.
Ja Moment, was sind die jetzt?
Aber wenn man mal darüber nachdenkt, ja, wenn man mal darüber nachdenkt, aus denen ihrer Sicht haben beide Recht, ja, weil, wenn man sich das mal so überlegt, ja, wenn man sich das mal aus Sicht von jemandem anguckt, der eher am rechten Ende da des Spektrums sitzt, für den ist natürlich der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk links, weil er nicht auf seiner Position oder rechter von ihm ist.
Also ist da nicht rechts genug, also ist der links
So, guckst du dir die
Guckst du dir auf der linken Seite des Endespektrums an
Dann ist der natürlich rechts
Weil
Der ist nicht linker und nicht genauso link wie sie
Also eher rechts, also die haben aus ihrer Sicht
Beide recht
Auch wenn es irgendwie weird ist
Aber das ähnelt sich teilweise
Aber da wollte ich
Gar nicht drauf raus
Ich hab gestern Abend
Bisschen Twitter
Gescrollt
Und da habe ich einen Comment gefunden.
Wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, auf welchen Tweet das war.
Das ist auch vollkommen egal.
Es geht darum, was er geschrieben hat.
Und zwar ging es in dem ursprünglichen Tweet...
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht. Ist auch egal.
Zumindest hat dann jemand geschrieben, als Antwort auf diesen Tweet.
Das wären ja alles Falschinformationen.
Und darauf hat dann jemand geantwortet, ja, deswegen ist es auch gut, dass deswegen jetzt Social Media mehr kontrolliert und eingeschränkt werden soll.
und da habe ich mir ernsthaft
an den Kopf gegriffen und habe mir gedacht,
Alter, wie bescheuert kann man sein,
dass man ernsthaft denkt
bei diesen ganzen
Social Media Diskussionen mit
Social Media erst ab 16,
15, was auch immer,
Altersverifikation, Chatkontrolle,
was auch immer, da geht, da würde es
irgendjemand um die Leute
selbst gehen.
Das ist teilweise so,
Niemand möchte Social Media einschränken, damit die Leute sich nicht falsch informieren oder sowas.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen, ich muss da ein bisschen ausholen, was mich an dem Kommentar so genervt hat.
Erstens, die Selbstverständlichkeit, wie die Leute das immer schreiben, so als hätten sie als einziger den Durchblick.
Ich meine, den einzigen Durchblick haben natürlich wir, Chat, da sind wir uns einig.
Ne, aber da muss ich mal sagen, Chat aus meiner Sicht, ja, meine Meinung, meine Meinung soll ich sagen. Also erstens, es ist wichtig, dass man auch Falschinformationen verbreiten darf, weil, jetzt kommt's, was sind Falschinformationen?
die wenigsten sachen sind 100 beweisbar richtig oder falsch ja es gibt ein paar mathematische
probleme diese kannst du beweise nicht beweisen aber es haben 99 prozent aller sachen liegen so
auf einer skala zwischen kommt zwischen 100 prozent richtig und 100 prozent falsch aber
Aber das Wenigste ist wirklich beweisbar 100% falsch oder 100% richtig.
Es gibt viele Sachen, da würde man echt sagen, ja, die sind wohl sehr sicher.
Also wenn jetzt jemand sagt, ich springe aus dem 20. Stock, ob ich das wohl überlebe,
da würde ich wahrscheinlich sagen, mit an Sicherheit grenzender Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht.
Aber es ist aber nicht 100%ig.
Und ich finde es wichtig, dass man Sachen sagen darf, auch wenn sie Blödsinn sind.
Ich meine, es ist eine Falschinformation, dass unser Bundeskanzler Eier leckt.
Keine Ahnung. Kann man so nicht sagen.
Aber es gibt viele Sachen, die heute noch als kann überhaupt nicht sein angesehen werden.
Und morgen vielleicht als ganz so unwahrscheinlich ist das Ganze doch nicht.
Deswegen ist es wichtig, dass man das sagen darf.
Und die große Preisfrage ist, ja, wer entscheidet, was richtig und falsch ist?
Weil wie gesagt, bei den wenigsten Sachen kann man es tatsächlich irgendwie, wie soll ich sagen, mathematisch beweisen, das was richtig oder falsch ist.
Ja, bei den wenigsten Sachen kannst du es beweisen.
Ja, zum Beispiel, ja, das ist übrigens auch ein Beispiel, sowas ist mir gerade eingefallen.
Ich kann jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, auf dem Pluto gibt es einen kleinen RF-Programmer, der da den ganzen Tag Kaffee trinkt.
bringt.
So, ihr werdet sagen, Max,
das kann doch gar nicht
sein. Aber könnt ihr es wirklich
mit Sicherheit sagen, dass
das nicht stimmt?
Man kann sagen, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,
sehr wahrscheinlich ist das nicht so.
Aber kannst du dir hundertprozentig
sicher sein?
Und ab wann machst du, ab wann machst
du den Cut? Ab wie viel
Prozent Sicherheit ist
etwas eine Falschinformation und wer
entscheidet darüber? Das ist der eigentliche
Punkt, ja? Wer entscheidet darüber?
Und es gab
die letzten Jahre über ganz viele
Dinger,
wo es am Anfang hieß,
alter Falschinformation oder besser
gesagt Verschwörungstheorie
und da musste man dann paar Monate später
darüber sagen,
vielleicht doch nicht
so verkehrt.
Deswegen
ist es meiner Meinung nach wichtig, dass sowas
nicht gefiltert wird und dass man sowas sagen kann.
Und das Wichtige
ist, dass die Leute
lernen, damit umzugehen.
Also wir
brauchen da die Kompetenz
bei den Leuten, dass die erkennen,
dass das höchstwahrscheinlich Schwachsinn ist,
ohne es direkt zu verbieten.
Weil sobald du anfängst, was zu
verbieten, hast du wieder den Punkt,
wer verbietet das?
Wie ist der ideologisch vorbelastet?
Wer entscheidet darüber?
Wenn die Leute selbst in der Lage sind, nachzudenken und zu sagen, ey, das klingt aber so unrealistisch, das ist bestimmt Schwachsinn, ist das viel wichtiger.
Und das ist eigentlich das Wichtigste.
Und wer wirklich glaubt, dass das irgendwie der Staat besser könnte, nachzudenken, als man selbst, für einen.
Ja, das halte ich aber mal für ein Gerücht, weil die haben schon mal ganz andere Interessen.
Als würde es da irgendjemand drüber gehen, als würde es da irgendjemand drum gehen, dass es den Leuten wirklich besser geht.
Guckt euch Chatkontrolle an, guckt euch die ganzen geplanten Überwachungsmaßnahmen oder die wahrscheinlich geplanten Überwachungsmaßnahmen an.
Da geht es niemand drum, wirklich das zu tun, was vordergründig gesagt wird, nämlich irgendwelche Leute vor irgendwas zu schützen.
Da geht es letztendlich um Kontrolle und die Kontrolle zu behalten darüber, was die Leute denken.
Und da weiß ich nicht, ob man sich einfach so auf Twitter hinstellen sollte und sagt, oh das ist gut, wenn das gemacht wird.
Ja, ja, deswegen, sicherlich alles Falschinformationen. Ich will, dass das jemand anderes für mich filtert.
Nein, das müssen die Leute bei sich selber im Kopf filtern können.
Die Leute müssen in der Lage sein, Informationen, die sie bekommen, filtern zu können auf, klingt sinnvoll, klingt bescheuert. Und es gab genug Sachen, da kann man sich auch mal historisch, man kann sich das historisch angucken, es gab genug Sachen, wo wir heute sagen, totaler Schwachsinn, was damals behauptet wurde.
Zum Beispiel, nehmen wir mal eine Sache, das ist noch gar nicht lange her. Ich kann euch nicht exakt genau sagen, wie lange, aber es ist noch gar nicht lange her. Da war der medizinische Konsens, dass Neugeborene, ihr könnt das googeln, wenn ihr mir das nicht glaubt, ja, da war der medizinische Konsens, zumindest beim Großteil der Leute, Neugeborene spüren keine Schmerzen.
Das ist kein Witz, ich habe mir das nicht ausgedacht.
Das heißt, Neugeborene kannst du auch beschneiden und sowas, ohne Narkose und sowas.
Das war damals Medizin, das ist normal gewesen zur damaligen Zeit.
So, heute wissen wir, kompletter Schwachsinn.
Damals wäre das Fake News gewesen.
Heute sagen wir, ey, wie kann man so dumm gewesen sein damals?
Das heißt, es ist auch immer eine Frage, wann wird irgendwas als Falschinformation klassifiziert und wer macht es? Und da findest du zig solcher Beispiele. Wir müssen jetzt gar nicht zu aktuelleren, aufgeheizteren Diskussionen gehen.
Es gibt viele Sachen, die aktuell diskutiert werden, da werden wir bestimmt auch zurückblicken in 10 Jahren und sagen, Alter, was da so die allgemeine Meinung war, war kompletter Schwachsinn, jetzt wissen wir es besser.
Deswegen, dass dort zentral irgendjemand für uns filtern soll, was jetzt richtig und falsch ist, halte ich für einen ganz gefährlichen falschen Ansatz.
Ja, das hat mich, deswegen hat mich dieses Twitter-Comment,
x-formally known as Twitter-Comment, ein bisschen getriggert gestern Abend.
Weil die Leute glauben das wirklich.
Die glauben es wirklich, dass es eine gute Idee ist,
wenn es eine staatliche Zensurstelle gibt,
irgendwie die Social Media filtert für die Leute.
Als kommt da irgendwas Sinnvolles bei raus.
What could possibly go wrong, ja?
Ja, das ist die gleiche Geschichte, wo jetzt angefangen wird mit Social Media Verbot oder Social Media erst ab einem gewissen Alter.
Was braucht man dazu? Natürlich Altersverifikation.
Ja, wie macht man Altersverifikation?
Man braucht eine Infrastruktur, um das Alter irgendwie zu überprüfen können.
Das heißt, man braucht da irgendwas auf EU-Ebene, wo man das...
So, und von da ist es dann natürlich zu Klarnamenpflicht und genau sehen können, wer was gepostet hat, auch nicht mehr weit.
Und wer da nicht erkennen kann, dass es da nicht drum geht, die Leute zu schützen, sondern um ein Kontrollmechanismus zu haben...
Das kann ich nicht verstehen, ja.
Wo bloß Stream wird verboten?
Joa.
Ey, weißt du es?
Stell dir mal vor,
stell dir mal vor,
es gäbe jetzt irgendeine Stelle,
die
auf Regierungsebene oder sonst irgendwie
entscheiden könnte, okay,
welche Social Media, jetzt zählen wir einfach Twitch mal als Social Media,
ja, welche,
welche Social Media Kanäle
erlaubt sind und welche nicht, ja.
Unter dem Vorwand, die verbreiten meinetwegen Fake News oder Falschinformationen.
So, jetzt stelle ich mich hier im Stream hin und sage XYZ leckt Eier.
Dann sagt diese Stelle, oh, gefährliche Falschinformationen.
Das wird gesperrt.
Und dann findest du noch Leute, die das feiern und sagen,
oh, gut, dass uns der Staat davor geschützt hat, vor diesen gefährlichen Falschinformationen.
Ich finde es bedenklich, dass das immer mehr hingenommen wird, Einschränkungen in der Freiheit, unter dem Vorwand, die werden schon wissen, was das Richtige ist.
Die wissen, also ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass die wissen, was das Richtige ist.
Oder sagen wir mal so, dass die glauben zu wissen, was das Richtige ist.
Allerdings nicht das Richtige für uns, sondern das Richtige, um Kontrolle auszuüben, ihre Macht zu behalten.
Nicht das, was für uns gut ist.
Also insofern, ich kann das nicht verstehen.
Ups.
So, genug gerantet.
Das kommt ja auch noch dazu.
Das ist ja auch was, was ich immer sage.
Man sollte vorsichtig sein mit den Befürworten solcher Maßnahmen, nur weil es aktuell die aus seiner Sicht richtigen Leute trifft.
weil wenn die instrumente erst mal da sind und es ändert sich was ihr macht gefüge
dann ist man ganz schnell auf der anderen seite ja deswegen sollte man sich eher fragen so ist
das sinnvoll dass diese maßnahmen und instrument dass das überhaupt alles geschaffen wird ja
Ja, das ist es.
So.
So, mein Wort zum Sonntag war das jetzt.
Chat, und ich hab mir überlegt,
vielleicht sollten wir mal im Stream,
nicht jetzt, ja,
irgendwann,
die nächsten Tage,
vielleicht sollten wir mal,
vielleicht sollten wir mal im Stream
ein Video aufnehmen für YouTube,
wo ich nochmal erkläre,
was das letzte Jahr bei mir los gewesen ist.
So einfach so mal als kleines Update
für YouTube. Bei euch habe ich es ja schon öfters erzählt.
Da müssen wir aber ein bisschen
Clickbait-Titel machen, okay?
Da müssen wir ein bisschen Clickbait-Titel machen.
Wir machen Clickbait-Titel
Ich war in der Psychiatrie oder sowas.
Das ist ja nicht falsch.
Das ist ja nicht falsch. Ich war ja tatsächlich in der Psychiatrie.
Aber halt nicht in der geschlossenen Psychiatrie.
Da müssen wir ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen
Clickbait muss sein. Da könnte man mal echt
ein Video im Stream aufnehmen, weil ich weiß, wenn ich das,
wenn ich das Offstream mache, dann habe ich wieder keine
Motivation. Das, das, da könnte man
wirklich im Stream mal ein Video aufnehmen, so 10 Minuten
für YouTube, so als kleines Update. Weil ich
kriege immer noch, ich lese das immer noch,
ich lese ja immer noch die YouTube-Comments, da
schreiben laufend, na gut, laufend, laufend ist
übertrieben, ja, aber alle paar Tage schreiben
da immer noch Leute, Max, wie sieht's aus? Oh, es ist
so schade, dass nichts kommt. Ich hoffe, es geht dir gut
und sowas. Also ein
Kleines Update auf YouTube wäre schon nicht verkehrt, oder?
Was meint ihr, Leute?
Kleines Update auf YouTube.
Was ich euch das letzte Jahr verheimlicht habe.
Nee, ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich finde das eigentlich ziemlich gut, ey, was ich euch das letzte Jahr verheimlicht habe.
Exzellent.
So.
Gut.
Chatkill.
Ich trinke mal kurz meinen Tee.
Übrigens, ich lag
falsch, muss ich dazu sagen,
letztens. Ich habe letztens
in einem Stream gesagt,
dass ich
nicht gesagt habe, dass es
wirklich hundertprozentig so ist,
sondern ich habe darüber nachgedacht.
Ihr erinnert euch ja noch an diese ganzen
Berlin-Hackerman-Geschichten.
Das da.
Da habe ich im Stream gesagt,
oder mal laut drüber nachgedacht, wäre es nicht sinnvoll gewesen,
wenn Berlin das Lösegeld bezahlt hätte.
Oder was heißt Lösegeld? Lösegeld ist das falsche Wort.
Weil ja die Hackermans irgendein gewisses Interesse daran haben,
sich daran zu halten, es nicht zu leaken,
weil die ja ihre Glaubwürdigkeit behalten wollen,
dass das das nächste Mal wieder so sein wird.
Aber ich habe ein Video geguckt von Hood Informatik.
Habe ich auch gesehen, der hat einen Twitch-Stream.
Also von dem Video habe ich quasi den Twitch-Stream von ihm gefunden.
Ich glaube, das ist hier irgendwo stand. Ja, genau.
Und der hat ein Video zugemacht.
Hier.
Warum Berlin nicht gezahlt hat.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ob er einen Short hat.
Und das finde ich klang...
...einleuchtend. Das können wir uns mal angucken.
Also ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch, was in Berlin los gewesen ist hier.
Wobei, das erzählt er vielleicht ja auch im Video.
Das können wir uns gleich mal angucken.
Ich finde die Argumente machen durchaus Sinn, warum die nicht bezahlt haben.
Und dass es auch keinen Sinn gemacht hätte, zu bezahlen.
Und eine Sache ist mir selbst noch eingefallen, gegen meine eigene Denkweise aus dem Stream.
wenn die bezahlt hätten.
Und es wäre im Nachhinein trotzdem rausgekommen.
Was meint ihr denn, wie groß der Shitstorm gewesen wäre?
So nach dem Motto, Berlin lässt sich erpressen, Lösegeld, Zahlung und sonst was.
Die hätten ja alle super krass darauf rumgehackt.
Also ich glaube, aus dem Gesichtspunkt, aus dem was er hier im Video sagt, gucken wir uns klar an,
war es doch die richtige Entscheidung zu sagen,
man bezahlt kein
Lösegeld. Oder wie heißt
denn das überhaupt? Das ist ja nicht wirklich Lösegeld.
Kein Schutzgeld oder so.
Das war wahrscheinlich doch die richtige Entscheidung.
Aber vorher
gucken wir mal, was
trendet denn auf Shithub so?
This week. Jawohl.
Let's go!
I have ADHD.
Okay, KI.
KI.
AI.
Nicht AI.
Aber auch nicht.
haben uns auch schon angeguckt.
AI.
Alter, was ist denn diese Woche?
Also ich bin es ja mittlerweile gewohnt,
dass irgendwie 80% KI ist,
aber diesmal ist ja alles KI.
Komplett.
KI-Dauerbeschallung, Alter.
Ja, da müssen wir uns gar nichts großartig von angucken.
Super.
AI, AI, AI, AI.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Rust.
Blazingly fast.
Leute, Blazingly fast ist es by the way nicht mehr.
Laserspeed ist es jetzt. Laserspeed.
Und falls ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt,
wo ist denn unsere
Chat?
Ah, hier.
Da haben wir es.
Wir haben
Ein Rusty-Mode, falls es jemand noch nicht gesehen hat.
Ich sehe das in meiner Vorschau gar nicht.
Was ist da los? Warum sehe ich das nicht?
Ich muss mal kurz FFZ-Settings öffnen.
FFZ?
Äh.
Chat, ich bin komplett verwirrt.
Bei mir gehen die...
Gehen die bei euch?
Bei mir in der Vorschau
bei FFZ ist...
Ach, jetzt geht's auch. Okay.
Okay, jetzt geht's auch. Das hat einfach nicht richtig
geladen. Jetzt
funktioniert's bei mir in der Vorschau auch.
ok keine ahnung
idk
so also was haben wir hier am start
ei
work trunk ist es hier ein vorgeht work
team management natürlich was was sonst
Alter. Natürlich.
Battlefield 3 mit DLSS 5.
Das Dumme ist,
ey, ich hätte ja tatsächlich Bock, ab und zu mal
ein bisschen Battlefield 3 wieder zu spielen.
Aber du kannst Battlefield 3 nicht mehr richtig spielen.
Die Rush-Server sind kaputt.
Seit drei Jahren oder so.
Die crashen immer nach 1-2 Runden.
Du kannst nicht mal ordentlich Rush spielen.
Ja, und Kongress ist auch okay.
Aber ich spiele halt gerne
Rush. Und Rush kann man nicht mehr
spielen, weil die Rush-Server kaputt sind.
Das fuckt mich richtig ab. Battlefield 3 Rush war besser.
Und leider haben sie Venice Unleashed irgendwie verkackt.
Hast du dir War Dogs angeschaut?
Ja, ganz kurz.
Ich hab mal bei Eddie und Lost Aiming reingeguckt.
In War Dogs.
Ich habe nicht viel geguckt, vielleicht eine Viertelstunde oder so.
Es hat für mich den Eindruck gemacht, es ist deutlich langsamer und mehr rumgestellter als Battlefield.
Also es ist eine ganze Ecke realistischer, ich glaube realistischer kann man das sagen, aber es ist eine ganze Ecke langsamer als Battlefield.
Ich glaube, das kann man schon sagen.
Oder ich kann es ja mal sagen, ob da mein Eindruck richtig ist.
Und was mich auch ein bisschen verwirrt hat ist, ich habe nicht so ganz gecheckt, aber wie gesagt, ich habe es auch noch eine Viertelstunde geguckt.
Ich habe nicht so ganz gecheckt, was das jetzt für ein Spielmodus ist.
Ist das so eine Art Extraction-Shooter oder was ist das?
Also wie gesagt, ich habe geguckt, an sich sah das ganz cool aus.
Also, den Spielmodus habe ich jetzt beim kurzen Reingucken nicht so hundertprozentig gecheckt.
Ansonsten sah das aber echt nice aus.
Ist das in der Beta?
Ist das Free-to-Play?
Oder wie ist das?
Early Access.
Und noch viel interessanter.
Wie sehr
fucken irgendwelche Heli-Pros
das Gameplay ab?
Control Zone.
Also es ist kein Extraction-Shooter,
was ich auch mal ganz gut finde.
Ich bin kein großer Fan von
Extraction-Shootern.
Okay.
Ähm.
Was ich jetzt nicht so ganz checke ist.
Ah hier.
Okay es ist.
Es ist.
Es ist Early Access.
Für 40 Euro.
Ja.
Aber wenn das Game gut ist.
Ich.
Ich überlege es mir mal.
By the way, ganz wichtig, hat das Ding irgendwelchen...
Also ich bin da immer ein bisschen skeptisch bei Spielen von kleineren Herstellern.
Und Bulkhead ist ja ein kleinerer.
Das sind übrigens auch die, die Dings hier programmiert haben.
Die sind Call of Duty, diese Call of Duty Abklatsch.
Battalion, genau.
Was an sich eigentlich auch ganz nice war, aber halt dead nach zwei Tagen.
Ich bin da immer ein bisschen skeptisch.
Ich hoffe, das hat keinen russischen Anti-Cheat oder sowas.
Weil es gab doch mal dieses World War 3 Game.
Und wenn du das installieren wolltest,
musstest du mail.ru Anti-Cheat installieren.
Hier, Leute.
Also...
Du musstest damals hier mail.ru Anti-Cheat installieren.
Und da habe ich gesagt,
ne, Leute, ne.
Das muss nicht wirklich sein.
Wie, wie, ich weiß nicht, chat, wie, wie, wie sieht's, wie sieht's bei euch aus?
Hättet ihr, hättet ihr Bauchschmerzen dabei, ein Spiel mit Mail.ru Anti-Cheat laufen zu lassen oder denkt ihr euch, ach easy?
Also ich, mir, mir hat das persönlich nicht zugesagt, Mail.ru Anti-Cheat.
Wenn er nur mail.cn. Genau.
Ja.
China-Chinesen-Anti-Cheat.
Da kann man sich wenigstens sicher sein.
Alibaba ist irgendwie dran beteiligt.
So.
Aber wir wollen noch gucken, was trendet denn.
in Rast diese Woche.
Aber die kommen aus England.
Ja, ich glaube nicht, dass es Mail.ru
Anti-Cheat hat. Wir können ja mal gucken.
WarDogs Anti-Cheat.
Ob die überhaupt was haben.
Okay.
Who has the best anti-cheat?
Riot Vanguard.
Ist das so?
Ist das das beste Anti-Cheat?
Valorant habe ich
seit Jahren nicht mehr verfolgt.
Also was trennt denn hier in Rust
schönes?
KI?
Open CAD Studio
Nicht, dass ich das brauchen würde
Aber für alle, die es brauchen, ist es bestimmt nice
OmniGet für Udemy-Kurse
KI
Connect
Cockpit Tools
Keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich auch KI
Seelen-UI
Customizable Desktop Environment
Moment, Moment, Moment
Das ist ein
Custom Desktop für Windows
In Rust
WTF, was ist das?
Ey, das sieht ja mal so aus
Also okay
Das Terminal ist nicht usable
Das Terminal ist unusable
Auf jeden Fall, also ne
Das sind wir uns einig, das ist komplett unusable
Weil zu viel Transparenz ist
Kann man bestimmt anders einstellen
Außerdem, nicer
Background.
Aber das sieht ja im Vergleich zu Windows
tatsächlich relativ usable aus.
Erinnert mich ein bisschen an Niri oder
ein bisschen i3 oder
Hyperland oder sowas.
Du hast hier mehrere Desktops, vermutlich. Keine Ahnung.
Das sieht tatsächlich wie was aus, was man irgendwie halbwegs benutzen kann.
Full Desktop?
Okay, und das gibt es
sogar im Microsoft Store.
hat es denn mehrere desktops
ich erkenne es jetzt nicht so genau
hat das mehr
was macht hier
hat das mehrere desktops
sieht man das hier
keine ahnung
Tiling Window, Mensch, das hat bestimmt mehrere Desktops
Ich denke auch, ja
Ey, das sieht ja tatsächlich
Das sieht ja tatsächlich mal usable aus
Webview-based, ah ja
Was willst du, was willst du machen?
Was willst du machen?
Das Ding ist
Windows-UI
Ist selbst unter Windows
So richtig beschissen
Also was willst du machen, Webview?
Ich kann es, ich kann es verstehen
Microsoft hat seit Jahrzehnten quasi kein ordentliches Windows-UI-Programm mehr anzubieten
Also Library oder API mehr anzubieten
Das ist komplett fragmentiert, ja
Windows-UI, das ist entweder
Windows hat mehrere virtuelle Desktops, ja, benutze ich ja hier auch, guck
Erster Desktop Windows, zweiter Desktop Linux
Aber unter der Haube sind das, guck hier, mehrere Desktops, ja, ja, ja
Kann Windows 10 auch, oder Windows 11
Windows 10-Konz, glaube ich, sogar auch schon.
Ja, ja, kann man machen.
Kannst hier unten über den Knopf, kannst du.
Ja.
Warst du nicht überzeugend?
Okay.
Ich schreibe mir das trotzdem mal auf.
Das können wir mal in der VM ausprobieren.
Einfach mal installieren, ein bisschen rumklicken.
Also ich werde es jetzt nicht auf meinem Host-System installieren.
Nicht vergleichbar mit Hyperland.
Gut, das liegt wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen daran,
dass der Windows-Unterbau halt einfach suckt.
So wie vieles unter Windows.
Aber um jetzt nochmal zurück zu gehen.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, wie beschissen UI...
Und by the way, ich rede jetzt tatsächlich nicht aus Erfahrung.
Ich habe es schon seit bestimmt 2-3 Jahren nicht mehr versucht unter Windows Native UIs zu programmieren.
Aber davor habe ich mich regelmäßig damit beschäftigt.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, wie beschissen es ist, UI-Sachen zu programmieren unter Windows?
Also das ist ja komplett fragmentiert und selbst dann funktioniert es dann richtig.
Also angefangen hat das natürlich alles mit guten alten Win32, API-Gedöns, was wir alle kennen.
Das funktioniert im Prinzip seit Windows 95, teilweise seit Windows 3.11 und funktioniert heute immer noch.
Ist aber komplett outdated.
Ist nichts, gerade GPU-Rendert, sieht null modern aus, hat auch keine modernen Bedienelemente,
hat Probleme mit Transparenz und Compositing.
Also das ist oldschool.
Dann gab es den Wrapper da drüber.
Dann gab es den Wrapper da drüber mit Windows Forms.
Windows Forms hat die gleichen Probleme, ist nur ein bisschen einfacher zu benutzen.
Ja, Windows Forms, aus meiner Sicht, für viele Anwendungen ist Windows Forms heute noch das Beste, wenn man, wenn man, kein wirkliches Windows UI programmieren möchte, sondern, oder ja, für einfache Windows UIs auch, sondern, also kein modernes, größeres Windows UI programmieren will, sondern, wenn man eine Anwendung hat, die den Fensterinhalt selbst rendert.
Also wenn ihr zum Beispiel jetzt einen Videoplayer programmiert, dann ist WinUI für das Management von den Fenstern und sowas gar nicht mal verkehrt, weil ihr könnt einfach, ihr bekommt einen Handle für das Fenster und ihr könnt das Fenster selbst reinrendern.
Aber ihr bekommt natürlich trotzdem von Windows, von WinForms immer noch die Events, Windows wurde resized und sowas, ja, kann man machen, andere benutzen SDL oder sowas für, aber wenn man vielleicht auch Windows Steuerelemente, das ist nicht verkehrt.
Also wenn man Sachen selbst reinrendern will, ja wir haben beispielsweise mal so einen GIF-Overlay gebaut mit Windows Forms,
ja, im Prinzip haben wir nur das Fenster von Windows Forms benutzt und den Inhalt selbst gerendert, dafür ist es okay.
So, danach kam Microsoft auf die Idee, sie machen WPF.
WPF ist das mit, mit diesem komischen, das habt ihr wahrscheinlich schon mal gesehen, mit diesem komischen XML für UI.
Ja, also so sehen UIs in XAML aus.
XAML ist quasi das Format, wie man
WPF-UIs
definiert.
Für die damalige Zeit eigentlich ein
cooler Ansatz, aber ich finde es ist heute
so krass eklig zu schreiben.
Es ist super verbose.
Es ist...
Du musst zig Adapter immer
programmieren und wie heißt das? Auto-Properties
oder wieder? Ich hab vergessen. Dependency-Properties?
Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr, wie das Zeug heißt.
Schon ewig nichts mehr mitgemacht. Also richtig...
Ich find's eklig, ja?
Also wenn ich irgendwas brauche, so irgendwas kleines, nehme ich lieber Windows Forms als WPF.
Problem ist, WPF ist halt mittlerweile auch komplett outdated.
WPF basiert auf, ich glaube zum Teil auf irgendeiner alten Direct2D-GUI-Rendering-Geschichte.
Ist glaube ich fest gelockt auf 60 FPS und ist auch nicht wirklich kompatibel mit modernen Sachen.
aber ein bisschen neuer, ein bisschen angenehmer
als Windows Forms, wenn man
GUI Anwendung machen will, ist aber auch
schon ewig nicht mehr geupdatet worden, wird eigentlich
auch nicht mehr richtig supportet
so, dann kam diese Ära bei Microsoft
wo sie gesagt haben
ey, sie machen JavaScript
und Windows
also diese Windows 8 Geschichte mit den
ich weiß gar nicht, wie dieses
Geschiss haben sie sich doch mal überlegt bei Windows 8
hier. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr,
wie das hieß. Metro. Metro hieß das, oder?
Nee, Metro war Windows.
Windows. Nee.
Wie hieß denn das? War das Metro?
Metro Style?
Vielleicht kann sich ja noch irgendjemand von euch dran erinnern. Keine Ahnung.
Da haben sie sich das überlegt.
Und da haben sie auch ein eigenes UI-Gedöns
für gebaut. Mit
JavaScript und Gedöns hat keine
Sau verwendet. Danach
kamen sie auf die Idee und haben
WinUI gemacht.
WinUI war quasi
weiterentwicklung von diesen metro metro metro die metro apps waren uwp war die
weiterentwicklung von den metro apps uwp gab es dann auch noch uwp ging nur in
der sandbox und war gemacht für windows apps die über den store vertrieben
werden hat kaum einer verwendet daraufhin gab es jetzt wenn ui 3 was
auch es ist ein super eklig fragmentiert das system und es hat schon seine
grund warum microsoft selbst die taskleiste by the way nicht in windows forms nicht in
wpf nicht in wp nicht in video gebaut hat nein die windows startleiste ist javascript
skript beziehungsweise stimmt nicht so genau ist react wahrscheinlich react native also
sich selbst die startleiste in windows 11 also eines der kern komponenten von windows 11 ist
nicht in der microsoft eigenen ui technologie für windows 11 programmiert das muss man sich
erst mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen also ist einfach bullshit was microsoft treibt komplett
Omega Bullshit ist das
Und der neueste Streich von Microsoft
ist ja
Der neueste Streich von Microsoft
Wie heißt es nochmal
Das ist der Nachfolger von Xamarin
Ähm
Maui
Das ist ja der neueste Streich von Microsoft
ein
GUI-Framework für .NET,
was Cross-Plattform ist. Cross-Plattform natürlich
ohne Linux. Linux gab es lange Zeit
oder gibt es immer noch, ich weiß es gar nicht,
nur mit Third-Party-Support.
Und das ist halt auch der größte Scheiß aller Zeiten.
Jeder fragt sich,
Maui ist so ein Ding,
seit Release wartet man
quasi jede Woche drauf, dass der Post kommt,
es wird eingestellt.
benutzt auch keiner hat auch bugs ohne ende und sagt so glücklicherweise gibt es mittlerweile
ein paar drittanbieter die versuchen dort netz kurs plattform irgendwie weibel zu machen so
avalon ja aber das ist auch xaml und ich finde ich finde ich finde ich finde es nervig also
um so kurz zu machen es gibt von microsoft nicht wirklich eine gute wie nennt man das so schön eine
eine gute UI-Story
für Windows 11.
Und nachdem Microsoft selbst ihren Kram
anscheinend nicht in ihrem eigenen
Gedöns programmiert, sieht man schon mal, dass
das Zeug nichts taugt.
Ja, das ist in der Tat eklig.
Deswegen finde ich Windows Forms
an sich nicht verkehrt.
Weil Windows Forms
das Windows Handling und die
Events für dich machen kann.
und den Fensterinhalt kannst du ja nach wie vor selber malen.
Ja, Windows Forms ist ja so ein kleiner Rapper über Win32,
du kriegst ja jedes Control-Element, hat da ein eigenes Window-Handle,
wo du theoretisch selbst malen könntest.
Und wenn du, sagen wir mal, einen Videoplayer oder sowas baust,
wo du wirklich den kompletten Fensterinhalt selbst renderst,
ist WinForms gar nicht mal verkehrt, wenn du einfach nur das Window-Handling haben willst.
Aber ich habe auch mal, einfach um zu wissen, wie es geht,
Windows UI Win32 gemacht.
Das ist absoluter Painschamp.
Ja, genau hier wie der Kanisterkoppel
schreibt, das ist absoluter Painschamp. Kannst du komplett vergessen.
Kann mir mal jemand erklären?
Chatge, was ist mit dem Stream heute
los? Der läuft gar nicht so
richtig an. Krebsen
irgendwas um 90, 100,
105 oder so Zuschauer rum?
Ne, also ich, ne, nicht, dass ihr denkt,
ich will euch nicht da haben. Aber mich wundert's immer.
gerade sonntagsmorgens haben wir sonst immer richtig viel.
Vielleicht
buggt Twitch auch gerade wieder.
Whatever.
Ich mach das ja nicht für die Kohle.
Meinung zu den Landtagswahlen?
Juckt mich da eigentlich nicht.
Ich würde es generell am schrumpfen.
Ja, das mag sein, aber nicht von
vor zwei Wochen 230 Leute
zu 100. Das muss
an der Uhrzeit liegen oder es kann auch sein, dass es
an mir liegt, dass ich einfach
uninteressanten Scheiß erzähle. Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Wird es wahrscheinlich sein.
So. Wir wollten aber
trotzdem noch gucken, was auf
GitHub trendet. Können wir fertig machen jetzt.
Hallo?
Äh.
Hab ich das irgendwie geschlossen oder so? Ach hier.
Also, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Was? Chat-GPT-Desktop-Application.
Nope.
Minecraft-Server.
Was? Offline-Privacy-First-Grammar-Checker.
Was für ein Ding.
Moment, erkennen die auch Twitch-Emotes als gültige Wörter an?
Das ist ja die große Frage, ja.
Moment, Leute.
Ist das etwa...
Ist das etwa in...
Ruby programmiert?
Ne, in Rust.
Leute, in Rust.
Blazingly fast, Alter.
Und warum genau...
Hä?
Warum hat der eine Ruby-Version hier drin,
wenn das Ding überhaupt nicht auf Ruby basiert?
der hat sogar ein gem-file
ok, keine ahnung
der hat aber alles mögliche drin
guck mal hier, der hat ein cargo
ein gem-file
ein package chasen
alter, was ist das für eine wilde
zusammensetzung
english grammar
jacker, ist was für mich
Hast du schon mal was mit
RC, Flugzeug, Auto, Drohne gebastelt?
Ne, hab ich nicht
Ich hab mir ein paar Videos angeguckt
So zu diesen
So zu First Person Drone Racing
Und sowas, sieht schon geil aus
Macht bestimmt auch mega Bock
Aber hab ich mich noch nicht mit beschäftigt
Was ist das?
DBX.
Lightweight
Cross-Platform-Database-Client.
Ist das quasi
sowas wie
Entity-Framework nur für Rust?
Aber
wie jetzt?
Ne.
Hä?
Ich weiß ja gar nicht,
was das sein soll.
Was bin ich da sehend?
Ist das ein Frontend der Datenbank?
Docker-Container startet oder was?
Anscheinend, oder?
But why?
Warum nicht einfach Docker run?
Okay, ich hab
legit keine Ahnung,
was das sein soll.
Die KI generierte Readme hilft jetzt auch nur so am Rande.
So eine kurze Zusammenfassung wäre eigentlich ganz nice.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Anti-Gravity-Manager, KI.
Outracer.
Google Workspace CLI.
DevEnv.
Ja, leider nicht isoliert im Container.
Das ist ja der Grund, warum ich DevContainer Sachen verwende.
Weil ich weniger anfällig sein möchte gegenüber Supply Chain Angriffen.
DC Switch.
Das ist KI, aber
vielleicht was, was man brauchen kann.
Zeig mal her.
Okay, kein Blasenschimmer,
was das sein soll.
Also, Leute.
Es ist ja schön und gut, ne?
Es ist ja schön und gut,
wenn man
Wenn man seine KI
Wenn man seine Readme
Brazor, Dankeschön für den
Massive Sub
Es ist sehr schön und gut, wenn man seine Readme KI
Generieren lässt, ja
Aber
Viel Text
Heißt nicht automatisch
Dass das klarer ist
Es ist sehr viel Text
Und es ist definitiv
KI generiert
Aber, ja, whatever, keine Ahnung
So
Also was trennt jetzt sonst noch?
Nix, was haben wir sonst noch Schönes?
Ähm, wir gucken mal kurz bei Go rein
Ob da irgendwas Spannendes dabei ist, wahrscheinlich nicht
Das scrollen wir mal kurz drüber
Die SSD-Preise, sind die
Sind die noch mehr gestiegen?
Okay, gucken wir mal
Samsung 990 Pro
Schauen wir mal hier
Die steigen ja noch weiter
Ich dachte so langsam, aber sicher
Hat sich's mal wieder erledigt, Alter
Alter, wie viel?
Ich hab mir
Moment, Moment
Wo ist mein Handy?
Ich hab mir doch eine gekauft
vor noch nicht allzu langer Zeit.
Warte mal. Mal gucken, was die hier kosten.
Moment.
Amazon.
Kurz suchen.
Das ist aber schon ein paar Monate her.
Aber da war es auch schon teuer.
Samsung.
Hier.
2 TB SSD.
Am 23. Januar habe ich mir die gekauft.
23. Januar
Also hier irgendwo
Guck mal, da hat es 283 gekostet
Lass mal kurz gucken, was ich dafür bezahlt habe
Ich habe dafür bezahlt
Wo sieht man das denn?
Order Details
Ich habe dafür bezahlt
244 Euro damals
Okay
deckt sich ja mit dem hier.
Und jetzt sind wir bei
320 wahrscheinlich.
So, und dann habe ich noch, dann habe ich im
Oktober, jetzt haltet euch fest, ich habe
mir im Oktober, also hier irgendwann,
hier irgendwann,
habe ich mir
eine 4TB SSD gekauft.
Für?
280 euro lol alter was kostet das ding jetzt
samsung 994 terabyte
da habe ich aber noch mal glück gehabt leute da habe ich mal richtig glück gehabt dass ich
mir die jedoch gekauft habe oder doch gerade doch mal gut gegangen
Fuck.
Das ist ja mal mega
krass, Alter, wie das gestiegen ist.
Da hab ich doch mal richtig Glück gehabt.
Ich hab die hier irgendwann gekauft, ne?
Also gerade, gerade
hätte ich das gewusst, Leute.
Hätte ich das gewusst, da hätte ich einfach
10 Stück bestellt oder so.
Ich wünschte, ich hätte damals mehr RAM gekauft.
Ey, zum Glück.
Zum Glück, kann ich nur sagen, Leute.
Zum Glück habe ich damals in die Tasche gegriffen.
Und mir...
Wo sieht man es denn?
Äh.
Chat, bin ich dumm?
Ach, hier oben.
64-Gig.
64-Gig DDR5 damals gekauft, als ich mir den Rechner geholt habe.
Das könntest du dir heute gar nicht mal leisten.
Heute würde 64GIG DDR5
RAM, und das ist auch noch...
Warum hast du eigentlich kein XMP-Profil
aktiviert?
Tja, weil ich krassen Overclocker-RAM habe,
der
Plus-Screens produziert, wenn ich das
XMP-Profil aktiviere.
Weil die den Scheiß
nicht richtig getestet haben.
Sadge, oder?
Und selbst testen,
wie viel er aushält, habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
So, zumindest
ich habe echt Glück gehabt, dass ich mir
Ende 2022 gekauft habe,
den Rechner.
Und da ging
das noch preislich mit dem RAM.
Jetzt würde ich für den RAM das gleiche
bezahlen wie für den Rechner. Jetzt bezahle ich wahrscheinlich
allein schon irgendwie. Wie viel kosten?
Wie viel würde mich, chat, jemand eine Ahnung?
Wie viel würde mich denn 64 GB RAM
aktuell kosten? 2000 Euro?
war jetzt einfach mal geraten.
Gucken wir mal.
Ähm.
Ja, der da. Guck mal.
Hier ist der Ram.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Oh.
Ha, ha.
Gekauft hab ich...
Ey, Leute, ich hab auch schon gekauft.
Guck mal.
Das war auch schon nicht billig, wo ich gekauft hab.
Da war's auch schon teuer.
Wo ich das gekauft hab, Ende 2022.
Aber jetzt ist es noch viel krasser.
Hier war's auch schon günstiger.
Zumindest wisst ihr, was ich immer...
Immer wenn ich meine Rechnerzusammensetzung mir angucke,
muss ich wieder den Boomer raushängen lassen.
Leute, ich sag's euch
Das hätte es damals nicht gegeben
Also damals
Als der Max noch jung war
Das hätte es früher nicht gegeben
Ich hab mir Ende 2022
Einen Rechner gekauft
Der war damals auch teuer, okay
Der hat damals auch
5000 Euro gekostet
Hatte die beste CPU
Mit die beste CPU drinnen
Super viel RAM
Ordentliche SSD
Beste Grafikkarte
Mit die beste Grafikkarte, die es damals gegeben hat
So
Dann hier vom Bauer
Ein Thermal Grizzly CPU
Contact Frame
Ich bin mir überhaupt nicht mehr sicher, wofür das eigentlich gut war
Aber
Der Auer wird es schon wissen
So
Wasserkühlung
das war absolute High-End-PC
Ende 2022.
Es gab, realistisch
betrachtet, gab es
nichts besseres
Ende 2022 als
Windows-Desktop oder Gaming-Desktop-PC.
Nichts besseres.
Und das Heftige ist, wir haben
jetzt Ende
oder ja, sagen wir mal fast,
der PC ist fast
vier Jahre alt mittlerweile. Fast
vier Jahre.
Und das Ding war damals
High-End und das Ding ist
heute immer noch ziemlich
High-Endiges Segment.
Das muss man sich mal überlegen.
Ein fucking vier
Jahre alter Desktop-PC
war damals super High-End
und ist heute
immer noch auf der High-End
Seite. Das ist ja
so krass. Das hätte es
früher nicht gegeben. Früher musstest du dir
sind nach zwei jahren nach eineinhalb jahren musstest du dir neuen rechnern
kaufen weil du die sachen wenn du glück hat das noch auf niedrigen details
spielen konnte
es ist so heftig vier jahre und fast fast nichts hat sich getan
naja kann vielleicht nachher gucken f programmer wobei das interessiert mich
was beim Kupferscam rausgekommen ist.
Welches Video ist das?
Ah, hier, China.
China Kupfer.
Aber das ist so heftig.
Also ich kann mich noch dran erinnern.
Ich hatte zu Zeiten, als Far Cry 1 rausgekommen ist.
Far Cry 1.
Falls sich da einer noch dran erinnert
Das war damals hier, ohne Scheiß
Das war noch nie dagewesene Poggers Grafik
Das sieht heute auch noch ganz annehmbar aus
Also Far Cry 1
Ich hab damals
Ein High End Rechner gekauft
Mit, ich glaub
Ne GeForce 3
Bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher
Irgendein Athlon XP oder sowas
Und der war ungefähr
1,5 Jahre alt
als Far Cry 1 rausgekommen ist.
Und ich konnte Far Cry 1...
Eineinhalb Jahre!
Also das war damals ähnlich guter Rechner
wie der hier jetzt.
Und ich habe damals Far Cry 1 drauf installiert
und konnte das in niedrigen Details spielen.
Und heute habe ich einen Rechner,
der vier Jahre alt ist
und ich kann immer noch alles
auf besten Details, die es gibt,
spielen mit ordentlich FPS.
Es sei denn, es ist ein schlecht optimiertes Unreal Engine 5
Game.
Dann hast du gelitten.
Aber trotzdem, das ist schon heftig, oder?
Total
Alta lahm.
So.
So sieht's aus.
So, dann gucken wir jetzt noch kurz fertig, was in Go
trendet. Wahrscheinlich nicht so
bei ki ki ki ki kennen wir schon ki ki ki ein crawling framework ago cd trendet
guck mal du kommst bei go in die weekly trends wenn du nur 73 sterne hast
schlecht agro cd ist kuba nettes business enterprise city gedöns wobei kann man das
die icd nennen nicht wirklich das stimmt nicht ja es ist eher es ist eher deployment ist es
nicht unbedingt also von dass die ii wird jetzt eher so was verstehen wie software auschecken
kompilieren container daraus bauen was das macht agro cd nicht agro cd deployed fertige
container quasi sorgt dafür dass die blumen aktuell bleibt ein projekt hat schon in go
getrennt excellent er klauen also im prinzip im prinzip ist agro cd eigentlich sehr nice
geschichte agro cd ist folgendermaßen versucht es mal kurz zu erklären für die ganzen kubernetes
check aus hier also stellt euch mal vor ihr habt eine anwendung die in kuba netz
laufen lassen wollte so was macht ihr dann ihr erstellt euch kuba in kuba netz
manifest wo drin definiert ist wie diese anwendung in einem kuba netz cluster zu
die pläne ist ja ihr habt dann ein manifest da ist ein service drin
da ist pot definitionen trainer welches image das verwendet werden soll blablabla
blablabla, Gateway-API-Definition und sowas.
So, ihr habt so ein fertiges und fertiges Package an YAML-Files
und wenn ihr dieses, wenn ihr kubectl apply macht quasi,
dann ist das dann auch in eurem Cluster drin.
So, das Ding ist jetzt, das ist natürlich ein manueller Schritt, ja.
Ihr habt YAML-Files, ihr müsst sie dann manuell applyen
und Argo CD automatisiert das.
Ihr gebt Argo CD in Git-Repo, wo die YAML-Files drin liegen,
von eurer Anwendung, die in Kubernetes laufen soll
und ArgoCD deployed die.
Und ArgoCD checkt auch, wann er deployed hat und was sich geändert hat.
Und wenn beispielsweise im Cluster einer was von Hand ändert,
könnt ihr das so machen, dass ArgoCD das wieder zurückrollt.
Oder aber, was viel cooler ist,
ihr könnt quasi mit einem einfachen Git-Push
ein Deployment starten in eurem Kubernetes-Cluster.
Was sind denn schon 100 Mal die Stunde Pollen?
Ja, also ich gehe mal davon aus,
ich glaube, man kann sogar Argo CD
notifizieren lassen über irgendeinen
Git-Hook.
Zumindest könnt ihr dann sagen, ey, ich will
jetzt die Image-Version von
meiner Anwendung, will ich eins hochzählen,
dann macht ihr das, pusht das ins Git,
Argo CD erkennt das und applyt das auf den
Cluster. Das hat den riesen Vorteil.
die dinge sind nachvollziehbar für alle weil es eben ohne dass du einen comment machst kannst
du keine änderung am cluster machen das heißt wenn ihr nicht irgendwelche irgendwelches frickel
stückwerk haben wollt ist agro cd ganz geil man kann es im zweifelsfall ausschalten weil es mal
wenn man wirklich mal ganz dringend von hand irgendwas hot fixen muss aber an sich ist agro
CD wirklich eine coole Variante und ich bin
echt froh, dass
bei mir auf der Arbeit in der Versicherung,
dass wir mittlerweile
Richtung Argo CD
umschwenken.
Was ist Argo CD?
Ja gut, ich hab's
ja gerade versucht zu erklären.
Wenn du eine Anwendung hast,
die in Kubernetes laufen soll,
dann hast du
ein Git-Projekt mit YAML-Files
drin ja in diesen jammer falls ist definiert was passieren soll im kuba netz cluster da steht dann
trainer du brauchst den ingress oder eine gateway api also quasi einstiegspunkt von außen zur
anwendung du brauchst ein service das ist das wie das im cluster verteilt wird du brauchst du brauchst
du brauchst eine definition wie deine container aussehen im cluster was die für ein image verwenden
sollen so das praxis alles in den github und ago cd guckt dann in dieses getriebe rein und
Applied das in deinen Cluster.
Continuous. Also sprich, sobald
du die Image-Version hochzählst,
also du zählst die Image-Version
hoch, pushst das in dein Git-Report, dann
Applied AgoCD das
in deinen Cluster.
So, und da gibt's auch ein
schönes Chat-Gil.
Man hat auch ein schönes Dashboard.
Da kann man gucken, was Argo CD so macht. Brauchen tut man das nicht unbedingt, aber wenn man nachgucken will, ob alles in Ordnung ist, auch okay. Aber also wie gesagt, Argo CD ist für mich, es gibt noch was anderes, es gibt noch Flux, aber Flux war eine Zeit lang nicht mehr maintained, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es das überhaupt noch gibt.
Also, Argo CD, würde ich mal sagen, hat sich durchgesetzt.
Und ich bin froh, dass wir in der Versicherung aktuell umschwenken auf Argo CD.
Von irgendeiner komischen, proprietären, zugekauften Lösung. Argo CD, beste.
Haben wir sogar schon mal im Stream gemacht.
Guck mal, Leute, ich kann mich einfach doch mal selbst zitieren, Argo CD.
Ist aber schon ein bisschen her.
Oh, haben wir das nicht?
Hier haben wir es doch.
Guck mal, hier haben wir meinen eigenen Stream.
Und hier haben wir Argo CD irgendwo.
Okay, guck, Chat, hier sieht man es.
Hoffe ich.
Guck, ich habe deployed.
Ich habe deployed.
Ich habe git deployed.
und Argo CD rollt das jetzt automatisch
in Cluster aus. Und zack, hier neue Änderungen
drin.
Das haben wir sogar im Stream
schon mal ausprobiert.
Und Argo CD kann sich witzigerweise auch selbst
kann sich auch selbst
managen. Ob man das will,
kann man sich rüber schreiten.
Ja, und wir haben das damals so eingerichtet,
dass sich der Kubernetes Cluster
quasi selbst hochzieht.
Über ein Argo CD Deployment.
Eigentlich ganz nice
So
Katana drin, ne
Next Generation Spidering Network
Ah, da kann man Webseiten crawlen
Meine Erfahrung mit Webseiten crawlen
Sind ja etwas gemischt
Ich musste schon zwei Entschuldigungsmails schreiben
Mal an ein
Domainregistrar
dass ich seine Webseite
gecrawled habe, dass ich wieder drauf darf.
Seitdem versuche ich so wenig wie möglich
zu Rap-Crawlen.
Und obwohl die mir in der ersten
Mail nochmal geschrieben haben, sie mögen es nicht,
wenn ihre Webseite gecrawled wird,
habe ich aus Versehen die Webseite nochmal gecrawled
und wurde wieder gesperrt.
Kann man nicht einfach IP resetten?
Nee, ich hab das leider an einer Kiste gemacht, wo sich die IP nicht so einfach resetten lässt.
Das war aber auch echt dumm.
Das war aber auch echt dumm, ne?
Also, ich weiß Recycle-Story, aber nur mal ganz kurz.
In diesem Video nur ganz kurz.
Also, ich hatte ein paar Domains registriert.
Was genau ist Crawlen?
Crawlen ist Content von Webseiten abgreifen, die eigentlich nicht dafür gedacht sind, abgegriffen zu werden.
Also, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel bei Amazon checken möchtest, ob ein Produkt verfügbar ist.
Amazon bietet allerdings keine API an.
Amazon bietet dir nur an, das auf der Webseite zu sehen zum Beispiel.
Dann könntest du jetzt ja auf die Idee kommen, du refreshst Amazon alle 5 Sekunden
und passt den Output und guckst, ob da drinnen verfügbar steht.
So, das ist Crawlen zum Beispiel.
Bei Crawlen vielleicht, das ist Webscrapen.
Das ist eher Webscrapen. Crawlen ist eher dann noch die Links durchgehen auf Amazon und dort auch Sachen zu parsen.
Also Crawling ist so ein Zwischending, ja, ist Webscrapen plus Links durchgehen.
Könnte man glaube ich so irgendwie übersetzen, ja.
oder zumindest, ich weiß, Recycle Story
aber nur, das war kurz zu erzählen, in diesem Video
nur ganz kurz, wie gesagt, also ich hab mir ein paar
Domains registriert, also ich hab
ein paar Domains bestellt
das ist schon ein paar Jahre her
bei einem Anbieter
der keine DNS
AP angeboten hat und
Chatgear High IQ Punkt zu gewinnen
wer weiß, wofür man eine DNS AP braucht
bei seinem Domain Registrar
erste richtige Antwort gewinnt
Chat geht's. Bin ich aber enttäuscht von euch.
Zertifikate.
Ja, Gott sei Dank. Einer wenigstens.
Meine Güte.
Ich hab schon gedacht,
IQ geht wieder abwärts im Chat.
Ich hab schon gerade gedacht, hier ist wieder...
Das da ist gerade angesagt.
Ja, Zertifikate, korrekt.
Leute, ich habe meine...
Maus irgendwie kaputt gemacht.
So.
Zertifikate, das ist richtig.
Und...
Third Auto Renew, korrekt.
Also, die hatten keine DNS-AP.
Und ich habe mir gedacht,
der Domainregistrar ist aber trotzdem schön günstig.
und ansonsten auch ganz nice,
wir können DNS-API
ja selber machen. Und zwar
habe ich dann mit
Puppetier,
vielleicht kennt das jemand von euch,
Puppetier ist ein Framework, wo man
in Chrome fernsteuern
kann im Endeffekt.
Da kann man dann sowas hier machen,
so hier, GoToWebPage,
PressKey,
so, und da habe ich
quasi einen
Webscraper
so ein bisschen gebaut.
Eine Webseitenautomatisierung,
die quasi DNS-Einträge
erzeugt, indem es im Webinterface rumklickt.
Leider
hatte ich da einen kleinen Fehler drin.
Und das Ding hat sich versucht, in einer
Sekunde irgendwie 80 mal einzuloggen.
Woraufhin der Anbieter dann gesagt hat,
oh, guck mal, von dieser IP
kommen komische Anfragen.
Wir ploppen den lieber mal.
Gut, habe ich hingeschrieben an den Anbieter,
habe gesagt, ey, sorry, Leute, mein Skript
ist ein bisschen amok gelaufen.
Ich sage euch aber, was ich machen
wollte. Ich habe eure
Webseite gecrawled, um
DNS-Einträge zu erzeugen, weil ihr keine
DNS-API habt. Bei der Gelegenheit mal nachgefragt,
vielleicht habt ihr ja mittlerweile eine DNS-API, könnt
ihr mir die sagen. Da haben die halt geantwortet, nee, sie haben keine
DNS-API und sie mögen es nicht,
wenn man ihre Webseite crawlt.
Ich soll das doch sein lassen.
Ja, das ist mir ja okay.
Dann lasse ich das halt sein.
Also habe ich an dem Skript noch ein bisschen rumgebastelt.
Nicht richtig aufgepasst.
Und ein, zwei Tage später
hatte ich das gleiche nochmal.
Hat der Anbieter mit einem M angefangen?
Nee.
Und zwei Tage später
war ich wieder gesperrt.
Da musste ich wieder hinschreiben.
Sorry, Leute. Ich hab dem dann
geschrieben, ich hab das
Skript angepasst für was anderes und leider
stand dann noch eure URL drin.
Und da haben die gesagt, ja, jetzt ist es aber gut.
Wir schalten dich nochmal frei, aber jetzt aufhören zu crawlen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich hör ja auf zu crawlen.
Seitdem hab ich die Webseite auch nicht mehr gecrawled.
Wie viel RAM ich habe
und dass ich so viele Tabs aufhaben kann.
Du meinst hier? Das ist doch gar nicht so
viele tabs kummer zählt story grenzen hier habe ich hier habe ich 80
gb ram nicht viel 8 gig und ein bisschen und ein bisschen swap
bei der ich sollte vielleicht jedoch mal wirklich jetzt endlich endlich mal die
zweiten acht gig einbauen aber wenn du wenn es dir um viele tabs geht hier
habe ich viele tabs damit damit so viele tabs das ganze aber hier habe ich auch
64 gig haben und das problem ist was mich ein bisschen abfuckt chrome lädt nicht alle tabs wenn sie im hintergrund sind bei koper
Ich habe noch 44 gig available wo sind wir denn hier ich habe
Ich habe 64 gig und das meiste brauche ich gar nicht
Also schon mal was in zwölf gemacht
Nachdem ich nichts für ios oder mac oder sowas oder generell apple geräte mache ich weiß man kann zwölf mittlerweile auch so benutzen
Aber ich sehe den Vorteil nicht außerhalb des Apple-Ökosystems.
Was schreibt der Robin?
Mir wurde mal mit rechtlichen Folgen gedroht und die haben einen Nons in der Logins Seite eingeführt, weil ich da mit einem Headless-Chrome im Kundenpanel war.
Wie darf ich mir das vorstellen? Irgendeine geheime Nummer, die sich hochzählt oder wie?
oder was haben die da eingebaut?
Ich kenne Nones nur aus
Blockchain
Richtung.
Max, was denkst du über das neue iPhone?
Ganz ehrlich, ich weiß, es war in letzter Zeit
vor ein paar Tagen, glaube ich, war das, ne?
War irgendwie Apple Presentation.
Ich habe nichts davon geschaut
und juckt mich auch
aktuell nicht.
Die Dinger
sind eh schon teuer as fuck.
Und
ich hab mein iPhone 14.
Das tut noch ewig.
Ich hab noch ein altes iPad. Das tut
auch noch ewig. Meiner Mutter hab ich
vor Jahren mal ein iPad Pro
gekauft, weil die den ganzen Tag ihr iPad
benutzt. Das tut auch noch ewig.
Ich mach da einfach
gar nix.
Achso, ich kann dir sagen, welche
anbieter das war bei the way ich kann dir sagen welche anbieter das war das nicht geheimlich der
anbieter ist sogar ziemlich gut den kann ich den kann ich mittlerweile ohne probleme hier
empfehlen hier parkbahn war das die sie nicht verkehrt also kann man wirklich nicht um eins
kaufen also war einfach nur günstige domains haben will sind die echt okay mittlerweile haben sie
auch sogar eine echte dns api
also ja mittlerweile eine echte dns api
hast du das für 2k gesehen soll ich mal gucken
iPhone. Apple. Welches ist das?
iPhone Duo.
Das iPhone Duo.
What the fuck?
Okay, ich bin ja manchmal immer ein bisschen skeptisch, was solche Dinge angeht.
und ich weiß, dass viele Apple-Leute
die Sachen kaufen, weil es von Apple ist.
Ich kann mir aber nicht vorstellen,
dass sich das durchsetzt.
Auch wenn es von Apple ist.
Und die Dinger von Apple zumindest
meistens in dem Zustand auf den Markt kommen,
wo man sagen kann, okay,
das ist halbwegs durchdacht.
Ich weiß nicht
Ich irgendwie
Ich hab da so ein schlechtes Bauchgefühl bei
Dass ich das nicht groß durchsetzen werde
Aber wer weiß, wer weiß
Mein Apple ist ja auch kein Garant dafür
Dass alles immer
Sich krass verkauft
Und best ever wird
Guckt euch mal Apple
Wie hieß das Ding?
Wie hieß die Feuerbrille von Apple?
Class? Ne, Class war Google
Apple VR geht uns an.
Hab vergessen, wie das Ding heißt.
Ich meine, für Leute,
ja, also ich überlege
gerade,
für Leute wie meine Mutter beispielsweise,
wäre das
von der Idee her
gar nicht
so schlecht.
weil die benutzt eigentlich nur ihr handy und tablet so und wenn die beispielsweise zum arzt
geht im wartezimmer sitzt liest die halt ihren kram auf dem handy nur wenn es sehr lange dauert
nimmt ihr tablet mit also für die wäre das vielleicht ja ein ganz gutes on in one gerät
mit handy und mehr lesefläche wie ein tablet auf der anderen seite weiß nicht
ob das wie groß ist das dann ausge ausgefaltet
ok zeig mal ja ein iphone wie krist marketing geblubbert kann apple auch gut
wie groß ist das jetzt das haben wir immer geil immer leute immer glückliche
leute auf diesen bilder ich darf ein iphone verwendet ich freue mich so iphone
ist das krass die sind immer so richtig am ausflippen ich werde immerhin immerhin
besser besser glückliche leute als weinende leute wie bei microsoft ja
Windows 11 Präsentation.
Der Typ hat fast geheult.
Dann lieber glücklich.
Und ich weiß, es ist super recycelt.
Aber weil so viele Leute immer noch nicht gesehen haben.
Ich zeige euch einfach noch mal eine Minute aus der Windows 11 Präsentation.
Dass ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Windows 11 Präsentation.
Hier.
Guckt euch diesen Scheiß mal an.
Der Dude heult fast.
Ich muss mal kurz die Musik ausmachen,
dass es dramatischer wird.
Der Dude heult fast bei der Windows-Präsentation.
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon.
Wherever you may be in the world, welcome.
Und der weint jetzt schon fast.
I'm so thrilled you're able to join us today.
I feel both honored and...
Das ist keine Satire, by the way.
Das ist die echte Windows 11 Präsentation.
Der Flint? Halb.
Ich meine, es ist alles Geschauspieler, die Möglichkeit geht's ja immer Marsch vorbei.
Aber das, das, Alter, dann ist mir doch lieber, dann ist mir doch lieber, die, die Leute sind, sind, sie sind glücklich und, und lachen, wenn sie das iPhone verwenden, anstatt wie bei Windows 11 halb zu heulen.
Ja, damals, damals war es noch kein Microslop.
Der ist wirklich fast am Einen.
Das ist so dumm! Das ist so cringe! Das ist so dämlich, Alter!
Das ist mein Haus.
Das ist ein Foto des Hauses, in dem ich geboren bin.
Und es ist das Haus, in dem meine Eltern heute noch leben.
Und obwohl es verändert ist,
es wurde renoviert.
Joa
Die absellen dir das doch bestimmt wieder, oder?
Ab, ab
Wie viel es wirklich kostet
Kannst du dir doch gar nicht sagen, ne?
Okay
Wir machen jetzt mal
Alter, na gut, okay, Speicher ist auch teuer
Aber Apple lässt sich diesen Speicher schon immer super krass bezahlen
Dann nehmen wir mal das kleinste
Eintauschgerät hinzufügen.
Okay, okay, was ist?
Das ist ja normaler, kein Eintausch.
Wir brauchen kein Apple Care.
Ja.
2299.
Nice.
Oh man.
Und wie groß ist das jetzt?
Wenn man das ausklappt.
Hab ich nicht gesehen.
Aber ich muss sagen,
Ich habe meine Zweifel, obwohl es von Apple ist und viele Apple-Leute super krass religiös sind, was Apple angeht.
Ich habe den Eindruck, irgendwie wird sich das nicht so richtig durchsetzen.
Vielleicht liege ich auch komplett falsch.
Und by the way, es gibt eine Untersuchung zu, die ist schon auch einige Jahre alt.
Da haben die Leuten so Elektronen an den Kopf geklebt und Gehirnströme gemessen.
Und die haben herausgefunden, dass wenn jemand gläubig ist und betet, egal welche Religion das ist, wenn jemand sehr religiös ist, wenn der betet, dann zeigt das gewisse Muster in den Gehirnwellen.
Und wenn du jemand, der großer Apple-Fan ist, Apple-Werbung und Apple-Produkte zeigst, erzeugt das bei ihm im Gehirn die gleichen Muster wie bei religiösen Leuten, wenn sie beten.
Was heißt, zwischen Religion und Apple-Fanboy ist gar kein so großer Unterschied.
Also für die ist das Religionsersatz.
Man könnte jetzt sagen, ja, jeder, der da mit offener Auge durch die Welt geht, der hätte das schon einschätzen können, aber nein, da gibt es eine Studie zu, das ist so.
Und ich könnte wetten, ich könnte wetten, dass das bei anderen Produkten auch so ist.
Also sprich, bei den Ultra-Playstation-Fanboys von früher wäre das genauso gewesen.
Oder, ja, bei den, was gibt's denn, was sind denn da sonst noch so die üblichen Kontroversen, ja?
Mac vs. Windows, Apple vs. Android
So Dinger
Bestimmt ähnlich, ja
Rust, Rust
Also, nicht bei den normalen Leuten, die einfach nur so Rust
Bei der Rust Taskforce auf Hacker News, bei den Rust Jüngern
Bei denen löst Rust auch sowas im Gehirn aus, bin ich mir ziemlich sicher
Andi, Dankeschön für den Sub
Ich muss mal gucken. Ich glaube, ich habe ein paar Subscriptions
vorhin irgendwie übersehen.
Exzellente.
Okay.
Mehr habe ich nicht.
Leute, die C++ verteidigen.
Sogar bei C++-Fanboys
wahrscheinlich wird das Gleiche
ausgelöst.
Ja.
Gut, zack, genug Apple geguckt
Applos
Warcraft 3 hat eine neue Kampagne
bekommen, tatsächlich
Oh, das finde ich aber cool
Hoffentlich taugt die was
und ist nicht KI generiert
Weil Blizzard weiß ja da nie
Eine Kampagne
für eine spezielle Race
oder ist das eine kleine Kampagne
für jede Race, oder wie ist das?
Weißt du das?
Da hätte ich tatsächlich Bock drauf, mal wieder Warcraft 3 zu spielen.
Ich bin nicht gut, was das angeht.
Ich spiele das immer nur in Singleplayer.
Mir wurde letztens das hier vorgeschlagen.
Was ist das?
Kann ich das einklicken?
Wow, viel zu laut.
New Warcraft 3
Kampagne.
Ich kann das nicht.
Okay, die Gamestar,
die weiß doch Bescheid.
Also es ist eine Undead-Kampagne.
wahrscheinlich oder
ok dann würde ich sagen es habe alle trends und softgit habe angeguckt so ein bisschen
geschwätzt ich habe von gesagt wir kommen zwar das video von und hund informatik an
warum es eine gute Idee war,
dass Berlin nicht die 2 Millionen
Schutzgeld bezahlt hat.
Nennen wir es mal Schutzgeld.
Lösegeld,
Löse-Dings-Stiftung,
weil ich habe ja auch im Stream gesagt,
vor zwei Wochen,
ich habe ja laut gedacht,
ich habe laut gedacht im Stream,
und ich habe gesagt, ey, wäre es nicht sinnvoll vielleicht,
wenn Berlin das bezahlt hätte,
weil
die Hackermans
haben ja ein gewisses eigenes Interesse dran, wenn sie das nächste Mal jemand erpressen wollen,
dass er sich auf ihre Aussagen verlassen kann.
Und sie deswegen das dann nicht veröffentlichen.
Aber mir ist selbst auch schon wieder was eingefallen dazu, dass es keine gute Idee ist.
Stellt euch mal vor, Berlin hätte das Schutzgeld bezahlt und es wäre trotzdem geleakt worden.
Wie riesengroß der Imageverlust und das Geflame und der Shitstorm gewesen wäre.
Hundeinformatik hatte übrigens einen Twitch-Stream.
gestern gibt es das video gefunden gestern auch mal gecheckt da war gestern
sogar live auf twitch also könnt ihr wenn ihr wollt und euch das gefällt
könnte bei ihm auf twitch vorbei gucken
15 Stunden vor.
Lass uns das mal von Hood-Informatik erklären.
Why didn't Berlin pay the 2 million euros?
What the fuck?
Welcome back to Hotatic.
WTF? Was jetzt?
Ah, YouTube, YouTube, geh weg.
Ey, diese Auto-Übersetzung, das ist so unglaublich dumm.
Warum denkt YouTube, ich will mir den Kram auf Englisch angucken?
Warum hat Berlin die 2 Millionen Euro nicht gezahlt?
Listen von Leuten, also von Mitarbeitern mit Namen, wie viel die verdienen und was ich auch ganz witzig fand, da gab es sogar in diesen Listen gab es Bemerkungen, wie die Performance der Leute ist und ob die auch schon mal krankheitsbedingt ein BEM machen mussten.
Ein BEM ist ein Berufs-, nee, ein Eingliederungsmaßnahme, glaube ich. Berufliche Eingliederungsmaßnahme? BEM? Ich glaube, berufliche Eingliederungsmaßnahme.
Ja, das ist, wenn du beispielsweise betriebliches Eingliederungsmanagement, ja, du hast recht, das ist, wenn du beispielsweise Langzeit krank gewesen bist und erst wieder zurück in den Job willst, also schon sehr sensible Sachen, wo man nicht will, dass die rauskommen oder auch irgendwelche Performancebewertungen.
Das Ding ist übrigens auch datenschutztechnisch echt bedenklich, weil eigentlich rechtlich gesehen müssen Informationen über das betriebliche oder berufliche Eingliederungsmanagement vertraulich gespeichert werden, sodass dann nicht jeder Zugriff drauf hat.
Also das darf auch nicht in der Personalakte direkt gespeichert werden. Das muss in der Extraakte gespeichert werden, weil nicht, dass das beispielsweise mal dein Chef sich durchliest oder so.
Ja, stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt irgendeine psychische Erkrankung zum Beispiel, ihr könnt deswegen ein bisschen weniger arbeiten, ihr seid vielleicht deswegen auch ein paar Wochen ausgefallen und ihr macht jetzt ein BEM und ihr besprecht das mit dem BEM-Beauftragten und ihr erklärt dem, was da Sache ist und ihr überlegt euch, okay, vielleicht machen wir das einfach mal stufenweise, wir machen ein bisschen Arbeitszeitreduktion und gucken, wie das funktioniert.
Und ihr erzählt das, es wird da reingeschrieben und dann kann euer Chef da einfach reingucken und sieht, ah, hier, der Typ hat psychische Probleme und sonst was. Wollt ihr wirklich, dass das der Chef weiß? Nee. Und, also ihr wollt noch nicht mal, dass das irgendjemand weiß, außer demjenigen, der daran beteiligt war. Und deswegen muss das getrennt gespeichert werden. Und war es da anscheinend nicht.
Also, die sind ja
wenigstens sind sie mit ihren eigenen Daten
genauso fahrlässig wie mit den anderen.
Das ist immerhin.
Immerhin machen sie schon mal mit dem eigenen Kram
genau diese eigene Unfähigkeit.
Und was ich auch gesehen habe, ich habe eine Passwortliste
gesehen.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Ähm.
Lasst mal gucken, ob man dazu ein Bild öffentlich findet, das ich euch zeigen kann.
Ne, aber ich habe einen Screenshot gesehen von den geleakten Daten und da war eine Passwort-TXT dabei.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob die Datei wirklich Passwort-TXT hieß, aber es waren Passwörter im Klartext drin gespeichert.
Also die hatten wirklich ein Passwort-Text-File und die Passwörter waren zu 80% eine Abwandlung von Amsterdam. Das war Amsterdam123Ausrufezeichen oder sowas. Oder es war underscore Amsterdam oder Amsterdam oder sowas.
Es war 80% der Passwort, da war Amsterdam
Plus irgendwas, um die Passwortrichtlinien zu erfüllen
Also es ist wirklich ganz unterirdisch schlecht
Aber gucken wir mal
Unterladbar für jeden, der einen Tor-Browser bedienen kann
Eine Gruppe namens Resider hatte Berlin erpresst
30 Bitcoin gefordert, also rund 2 Millionen Euro
Und Berlin hat nicht gezahlt
Wenn du die Screenshots auf X gesehen hast
Ich habe gestern bei Hood Informatik, ich war kurz im Stream,
er ist gerade am überlegen, ob er sich mit Face vor die Kamera setzt oder nicht.
Muss jeder selbst wissen.
Aber wenn er mich fragen würde, würde ich ihm sagen, lass es lieber bleiben,
wenn du deine Ruhe haben willst.
Denkst du dir jetzt vermutlich, wie kann man da bitte nicht zahlen?
Bleib dran, denn die Antwort ist überraschender, als du denkst.
Der Ablauf in diesem Fall erzählt schon die halbe Geschichte.
Die Angreifer saßen rund eine Woche im August unbemerkt in den Netzen von zwei Senatsverwaltungen und zogen in aller Ruhe Daten ab, bis der Angriff eher zufällig aufflog.
Offiziell hieß es erst, es seien nur öffentlich verfügbare Geodaten weg.
Ja, bla bla bla. By the way, es kann durchaus sein, dass sie zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht mal bewusst gelogen haben,
sondern selbst keinen Plan hatten, was eigentlich abgeflossen ist.
Ja, was Talks angeht auf dem CC, das kann man ja machen, aber es ist ein Unterschied, ob man quasi das Gesicht in jedem Video sieht, ich weiß ja nicht, was er plant, oder wirklich nur Interessierte da einen Talk finden.
Also gerade in dem Bereich, glaube ich, ist es nicht verkehrt, wenn nicht jeder dich auf der Straße erkennt.
Aber, wie gesagt, das ist jetzt nicht unser Problem.
Ein paar Tage später musste man aber einräumen, naja, personenbezogene und nicht öffentliche Daten wurden kopiert.
Das ist ein Muster, das du dir merken kannst, denn die erste offizielle Zahl bei so einem Vorfall ist fast immer die schönste, die man gerade noch verkaufen kann.
Und kurze Zeit später kam raus, was wirklich abgeflossen ist.
Und das ist einer der schlimmsten Behördenleaks, den Deutschland je gesehen hat.
Auf der persönlichen Ebene...
Was auch witzig ist, wisst ihr, was mir da jetzt gerade so einfällt?
Das war so 1, 2 Tage, 3 Tage vielleicht in den Medien und danach hat keine Sau mehr drüber geredet, oder?
Nichts mehr.
Da irgendwie drauf Einfluss genommen wurde, Keck Alu.
... von über 12.000 direkt betroffenen Menschen.
Im Paket stecken über 16.000 E-Mail-Adressen, knapp 12.000 Telefonnummern, E-Bahns, dazu Personalakten, Disziplinarverfahren, Gehaltsabrechnungen und die privaten Bankdaten von Führungskräften.
Kritisch wird das bei den Reha-Unterlagen, Krankausschreibungen, Attesten und Angaben zum Behinderungsgrad einzelner Mitarbeiter.
Denn das ist keine Kleinigkeit, sondern die kritischste Kategorie in der DSGVO überhaupt.
Gesundheitsdaten fallen nämlich unter Artikel 9 der DSGVO, die besonderen Kategorien personenbezogener Daten, also die Sorte mit dem allerhöchsten gesetzlichen Schutz.
Und genau die liegen jetzt offen im Netz.
Wenn man sich an solche Datenleaks anguckt, wie in Berlin, also erstens, man wird es wahrscheinlich nie komplett verhindern können, ja, irgendwas wird immer passieren.
Aber da muss man sich mal überlegen, möchte man den gleichen Leuten denn wirklich auch seine privaten Daten an...
...überlassen. Überlassen ist das Falschwort. Geben.
Fängt an mit elektronischer Patientenakte, geht weiter mit irgendwelchen Klarnamen, Pflichts, Fantasien, Chatüberwachung, Altersverifikationen.
Will man den Leuten, die so unfähig sind, das wirklich geben?
Also ich für meinen Teil nicht.
Habe dir mal Gedanken, denn ein geleaktes Passwort ist ärgerlich.
Aber du änderst es in wenigen Sekunden.
Eine kompromittierte IBAN lässt sich austauschen.
Eine Telefonnummer zur Not auch.
Aber deine Krankengeschichte kannst du nicht ändern.
Und auch deinen Behinderungsgrad änderst du nicht.
Ein Disziplinarverfahren, eine Geburtsurkunde, deine Rehaakte.
All das sind Dinge, die zu einem Menschen gehören und die er nicht einfach zurücksetzen kann.
Einmal im Darknet heißt praktisch für immer draußen.
Kopiert, gespiegelt, immer wieder neu hochgeladen.
Das bedeutet, bei genau diesen Daten gibt es kein Zurück.
Und deshalb wiegen sie so viel schwerer als jedes Passwort.
Aber es geht noch weiter, denn so schlimm das für die Betroffenen ist,
existiert eine zweite Ebene, die mindestens genauso gefährlich ist.
Denn unter den Dateien finden sich Zivilschutzpläne und Listen von Objekten,
die im Verteidigungsfall besonders geschützt werden müssen.
Also Heizkraftwerke für Krankenhäuser,
Ja, das willst du nicht wirklich im Internet haben, ne?
...Anlagen, Umspannwerke.
Das ist im Grunde eine Landkarte dessen, was man treffen müsste, um die kritische Infrastruktur einer Hauptstadt lahmzulegen.
Dazu Schwachstellenanalysen zur Trinkwasserversorgung.
Na gut, Berlin legt ja freiwillig schon ihre Infrastruktur lahm.
Und ein Ordner mit dem Titel AG-CBRN-Rahmenplanung.
CBRN steht für Chemisch, Biologisch, Radiologisch und Nuklear.
Also die Notfallplanung für den absoluten Ernstfall.
Material, das als Verschlusssache eingestuft sein müsste und niemals auf einem normalen Dateiserver einer Senatsverwaltung etwas zu suchen hat.
Was uns zur eigentlichen Frage bringt.
Wenn da Zivilschutzpläne und Gesundheitsdaten drinstecken, warum kauft man sich dann nicht einfach frei?
Warum wirft man nicht einfach die 2 Millionen hin und ist die Sache los?
Bei klassischer Ransomware läuft es nämlich so.
Die Angreifer verschlüsseln deine Daten, du kommst nicht mehr ran und gegen Zahlung bekommst du einen Decryptor, also den Schlüssel, um alles wieder lesbar zu machen.
In diesem Modell liefern die Banden tatsächlich oft, und zwar aus kaltem Eigeninteresse.
Würde sich rumsprechen, dass Zahlen nichts bringt, würde niemand mehr zahlen und ihr ganzes Geschäftsmodell bräche zusammen.
Es gibt sogar Gruppen mit Kundensupport, damit die Entschlüsselung klappt.
Aber...
Na gut, aber, aber, aber, na gut, na gut, dann muss ich mal sagen, an der Stelle...
Wenn dein Fileserver verschlüsselt wird, so eine wirkliche Garantie, dass die Daten vorher keiner gelesen hat, hast du nicht.
Es sei denn, du hast alles gelockt und aufgezeichnet.
Und das ist wichtig. Berlin fällt nicht in diese Kategorie.
Denn in Berlin wurde nichts verschlüsselt, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Denn die Systeme liefen, der Senat kann weiterarbeiten.
Die Daten waren also nie unzugänglich.
Es wurden schlicht Kopien abgezogen und mit Veröffentlichung gedroht.
Und damit ändert sich alles, denn hier kaufst du keinen Decryptor, sondern du kaufst ein Versprechen.
Das Versprechen, dass eine kriminelle Bande ihre eigene Kopie deiner Daten löscht.
Und genau da fällt jedes Argument fürs Zahlen in sich zusammen.
Frag dich mal konkret, welche Garantien hättest du?
Du hast keine Garantien, aber du hast bei irgendeinem Ransomware-Angriff, wenn du nicht alles mitgelockert hast, auch keine Garantien, dass die vom Verschlüssel nicht was runtergeladen haben.
2 Millionen und bekommst als Gegenleistung ein, ja, die Daten sind gelöscht. Das war's.
Du kannst es nicht überprüfen und zwar nie. Es gibt kein Belege, keine Kontrolle und kein Zurück.
Du vertraust darauf, dass ausgerechnet die Leute, die dich gerade erpressen, ehrlich sind, wenn niemand mehr hinschaut.
Und selbst wenn du glaubst, dass die ihr Wort halten, arbeitet Resider als Ransomware as a Service.
Das heißt, die Gruppe baut die Werkzeuge und die Infrastruktur, aber die eigentlichen Angriffe fahren angeworbene Partner, die sogenannten Affiliates.
Und die Beute wird geteilt. Das ist Teamarbeit über mehrere Parteien hinweg.
An deinen Daten hatten also potenziell mehrere Leute die Hände.
Selbst wenn der eine seine Kopie löscht, liegt sie längst noch auf dem Rechner des Partners, im Backup der Infrastruktur oder auf irgendeinem Server, den niemand mehr überblickt.
Eine digitale Kopie ist nicht wie ein Gestorbenes.
Wisst ihr, dementsprechend, selbst wenn die das nicht veröffentlichen, du hast keine Garantie.
Und im Zweifelsfall kommt einen Monat später jemand anderes und sagt, ey, du hast doch da 2 Millionen bezahlt, willst du nicht bei uns auch mal 2 Millionen bezahlen?
... das Gemälde, das man zurückgibt. Denn die Dateien lassen sich beliebig oft vervielfältigen und du kannst nie beweisen, dass die letzte weg ist.
Womit wir beim nächsten Punkt sind
Nichts hindert dieselbe Bande daran, dich einfach ein zweites Mal zu erpressen
Sie haben die Daten ja noch
Sie können in sechs Monaten wiederkommen und unter demselben Namen oder unter neuem Namen nochmal kassieren
In Berlin lief die Darknet-Auktion sogar schon, während die Zahlungsfrist noch tickte
Die Daten waren also längst auf dem Markt und du hättest zwei Millionen überwiesen
Und die Daten wären trotzdem draußen
Und selbst wenn...
Und es hätte einen riesen Shitstorm gegeben
Wenn die überwiesen hätten
Und die Daten trotzdem geleakt
worden wären, was ja wohl
der Fall ist, in dem, ja, was ja wohl
so gewesen wäre, hätten sie bezahlt.
All das nicht wäre, bliebe
das grundsätzliche Argument. Wer zahlt,
sendet ein Signal. Nach außen wirkt das also
wie, hey, wir wurden gehackt und in solchen
Fällen zahlen wir. Damit machst du dich und
jede andere Behörde zum lohnenden Ziel.
Und jeder gezahlte Euro ist außerdem
das Startkapital für den nächsten Angriff.
Dieselbe Resider-Gruppe hatte vorher nämlich
schon die British Library in London platt gemacht
und dieses Jahr Stuttgart getroffen.
Die British Library hat nicht gezahlt, die Daten wurden geleakt und der Wiederaufbau kostete sie bis zu 7 Millionen Pfund.
Bitter, aber hätten sie gezahlt, wäre genau dieses Geld in den nächsten Coup geflossen.
Baltimore weigerte sich 2019 ebenfalls.
Die Wiederherstellung verschlang geschätzte 18 Millionen Dollar.
Doch die Stadt bekam saubere Systeme und fütterte keine kriminelle Bank.
Die Frage ist, ob Berlin auch saubere Systeme jetzt bekommt.
Oder ob hier einfach alles so weiterlaufen lässt.
By the way, ich habe irgendwo gelesen, in irgendeiner News, dass in Berlin jetzt CrowdStrike gucken soll, dass alles sicher ist.
Als hätte CrowdStrike selbst noch nie Probleme gehabt.
Deshalb ist die Linie der deutschen Sicherheitsbehörden seit Jahren dieselbe.
Das BKA bringt sie auf die Formel, kein Lösegeld zahlen, jede Erpressung anzeigen.
Und der Chaos Computer Club hat Berlins Entscheidung ausdrücklich gelobt, weil man diese Gruppe sonst dauerhaft am Leben hält.
Dazu kommt ein rechtliches Risiko, das gern vergessen wird.
Wer an eine sanktionierte Gruppe zahlt, kann sich unter Umständen sogar selbst strafbar machen.
Nicht zu zahlen war also die einzig saubere Entscheidung und trotzdem ist das hier keine Erfolgsgeschichte.
Denn die eigentliche Frage ist nicht, ob man zahlt, sondern warum eine Woche unbemerkter Zugriff überhaupt in einen Totalschaden dieser Größe kippen konnte.
Und da fangen die eigentlichen Probleme an.
Diese Daten lagen offenbar im Klartext auf den Servern.
Verschlüsselung und wie gesagt Passwort-TXT-Files und sowas.
Im Ruhezustand, also at rest, hätte bedeutet, dass die Angreifer die Dateien zwar abziehen, damit aber nichts anfangen können.
Genauso fehlte offenbar eine saubere Netzwerksegmentierung.
Ein Landesnetz sollte in getrennte Zonen aufgeteilt sein, sodass jemand, der in einem Bereich sitzt, eben nicht automatisch an alles andere kommt.
Wenn ein einziger Kompromittiert...
Das sollte so sein, ja.
...Zugang reicht, um sich quer durch Zivilschutzpläne, Personalakten und CBRN-Unterlagen zu bewegen, dann fehlte genau diese Trennung.
Verschlüsselung und Segmentierung hätten aus einem Kassas-Programm...
Was ich aber an der... Übrigens, was ich an der Stelle aber auch witzig finde, ne?
Also ich kenne mich ja, was so Vorgaben angeht, in der Finanzbranche mittlerweile ganz gut aus.
Wie gesagt, ich habe bei einer Bank gearbeitet, jetzt arbeite ich bei einer Versicherung. Da gibt es ja viele Vorgaben. Und da gibt es auch immer regelmäßige Outits, wo geguckt wird und alles. Die Vorgaben sind super umfangreich und krass und keiner weiß so genau, ob man sie überhaupt richtig erfüllt, weil die teilweise auch ein bisschen schwammig sind.
Gibt es wirklich Monster an Vorgaben? Was in gewissem Rahmen auch gar nicht verkehrt ist, ja? Warum gibt es die nicht da auch? Und warum wird die da nicht kontrolliert?
... vielleicht einen unangenehmen, aber beherrschbaren Zwischenfall gemacht.
Und zum Schluss ein Punkt, der mir wirklich wichtig ist.
So spannend so ein Leak technisch auch ist und so verlockend es auch sein mag,
mal eben in den Tor-Browser zu schauen, was da alles drin steht,
vergisst bitte nicht, hinter diesen 1,4 Millionen Dateien stehen echte Menschen.
Das ist die Sachbearbeiterin, deren Reha-Akte jetzt jeder lesen kann.
Der Beamte, dessen Disziplinarverfahren offen liegt.
Die Familie, deren Adresse und Kontodaten im Netz stehen.
Diese Leute haben sich das nicht ausgesucht.
Geht mit solchen Daten nicht leichtfertig um und verbreitet keine Screenshots mit Klarnamen.
Ladet euch das Zeug also nicht aus Neugier runter.
Was für...
Also Screenshots mit Klarnamen habe ich tatsächlich nicht gesehen.
Ich habe nur Passwörter gesehen.
Äh, auf Screenshots. Irgendwas mit Amsterdam.
Ein spannender Datensatz ist, ist für jemand anderen das eigene Leben, das plötzlich öffentlich wurde.
Und ich hoffe, jetzt versteht ihr, warum nicht zu zahlen das einzig Richtige war.
Und damit stay safe und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Okay. Klingt alles nachvollziehbar.
Übrigens hier, Sticky Note am Monitor ist besser als der Ruf.
Weil der Vorteil von Sticky Note am Monitor ist,
wie nennt man das so schön? Die sind airgapped.
Genau, die sind airgapped.
Also wenn jemand euren Rechner übernommen hat,
kann er sich zwar ohne Probleme alles auf dem Rechner angucken,
Aber wenn ihr nicht gerade irgendwie eine Drohne in der Wohnung habt, die ihr vom Rechner aus fernsteuern könnt, oder diesen, oder einen Staubsaugerroboter mit einer Zoom-Kamera oder whatever, dann wird es ziemlich schwierig, das Sticky Note am Monitor auszulesen.
Also Zettel mit Passwort und Secrets, meiner Meinung nach sind die besser als ihr Ruf.
Wenn jemand einbricht und den PC klauen möchte, ist das nicht so optimal.
Das stimmt, ja.
Irgendwas hast du immer?
Mal gucken, was beim Bauer so los ist.
China-Kupfer-Update.
Der Fall mit dem falschen...
Ich Face-Reveale nicht.
Außerdem wurde mein Face doch schon längst revealed
in der China-Suppe.
Weiß man, wie die auf die Systeme gekommen sind?
So genau habe ich das nicht verfolgt.
Keine Ahnung.
Weiß man nicht.
Weiß ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Oh, das wäre doch mal ein Thema, oder?
Erstes Face-Reveal.
Genau, bei einer Million Abos Face-Reveal.
Ich mache einen Konferenztalk, wie beschissen C++ ist.
Wir können ja mal googeln.
Berlin, wie hießen die?
Die Residia?
Wie lief der Einbruch?
Das Eindringen
Ein Angestellter reagierte auf eine gefälschte E-Mail
Beim Öffnen des Anhangs
Schleuste der Klassiker
Schlechthin
Der Klassiker
Schlechthin, Alter
Was PowerShell?
Ich weiß nicht. Ich habe darüber nichts gelesen,
wie es im Detail lief.
Ja, Heiser hat da was zugeschrieben.
Also.
Okay, ein gefaktes Captcha
verleiht so schnell wie...
Über die PowerShell...
Was?
Über die PowerShell wird dann ein böses...
Okay, also die haben irgendwie ein gefaktes Captcha
und im gefakten Captcha
steht, dass man irgendwas in die PowerShell
einführen soll. Alter, das ist ja doppelt
dumm.
Die ersten Captchas von Cloudflare müssen
um effektiv zu sein immer ein wenig anders
aussehen und vom Nutzer verschiedene Dinge
verlangen. Das muss dann auch ein paar Mal
das zu drücken und nicht etwas...
Ah, okay.
Okay, da musst du sogar
einen PowerShell-Skript reinpasten.
Tja.
Die Sache ist halt die,
warum
hat ein Angestelltenrechner
überhaupt so viele Rechte?
Also ein Verwaltungsangestelltenrechner
Erstens, warum hat er überhaupt PowerShell-Rechte?
Braucht er nicht.
Weiß er gar nicht, was es ist.
Und
warum dürfen da Sachen ausgeführt werden,
die nicht signiert sind?
Oder white-listed sind?
Das war's für heute.
Hier ist die komplette Attacke.
Lass uns mal gucken.
Okay, so sah das Captcha aus.
Es sieht schon nach einem echten Captcha aus.
Natürlich ist jedem von uns bewusst,
dass sobald sowas drin ist,
das natürlich Blödsinn ist.
Aber wir sind ja auch technisch
nicht
komplette Noobs.
Kann ich mich trauen, das anzuklicken?
Ich muss erstmal Vorschau gucken, was das für eine Seite ist.
Okay, ist anscheinend richtig.
Ich esse das Richtige.
muss immer bevor ich links aufmachen manchmal checken jetzt das alles passt
aber anklicken
feldklaut flim plus er mehr als 40 s max ach guck mal hier essen
Deswegen trainiert man ja auch seine User drauf, nicht irgendwelche Links anzuklicken und nicht irgendwelche Terminalbefehle einzufügen.
Nicht irgendwelche komischen Warnungsdinger wegzuklicken.
Die Mitarbeiter müssten, ja, müssten, waren sie wahrscheinlich nicht.
Oder vielleicht hat er nicht richtig aufgepasst.
Ich meine, so eine Schulung ist ja keine 100% Sache.
so sieht's aus ist schon gut gemachte captcha seite ja muss man sagen
Es ist aber wieder der Klassiker gewesen.
Phishing und irgendwelche E-Mail-Anhänge.
Bei dem Berliner Ding?
Ne, wir haben uns nur gerade ein Video dazu angeguckt,
warum es gut war, dass die kein Lösegeld bezahlt haben.
Video zu Fake Captures.
Hallo? YouTube? Hallo? Hallo YouTube?
ok
youtube hat kein bock
trotzdem also was immer die gleichen sachen also bei uns auf der arbeit ist es so auf den
Windows-Kisten für alle Mitarbeiter ist es so, also das ist übelst nervig zu benutzen,
aber ich verstehe es, warum es so gemacht ist, die haben eine Whitelist. Also es dürfen nur
signierte und whitelistete Anwendungen überhaupt ausgeführt werden.
das fängt schon mal viel ab von wegen führen sie einfach mal dieses gedöns aus was im anhang ist
auf der anderen seite das lässt sich sicherlich aus tricksten ja wenn du eine anwendung findest
die selbst angreifbar ist und der du dort irgendwie diesen prozess custom funktion einschleusen kannst
das ist bestimmt auch was machen
und
PowerShell-Rechte
haben die meisten Leute auch nicht.
Also die können gar keine
PowerShell starten bei sich auf dem Arbeitswindows
und Notebook. Was aber auch okay ist,
finde ich, weil, guck mal,
braucht die Sekretärin PowerShell?
Die weiß wahrscheinlich nicht mal, was das ist.
Braucht irgendwie eine aus dem Controlling PowerShell?
Der weiß auch nicht mal, was das ist.
damit kannst du auch viel abfangen aber hundertprozentig sicher bist natürlich nie
selbst der betreiber von herbergen ist schon auf phishing reingefallen klar die sachen werden ja
auch immer besser und sind immer besser gemacht übrigens das ist auch der grund weil sie jetzt
nicht explizit phishing aber supply chain angriffe das ist auch der grund warum ich nur noch wenn ich
was programmieren mache ich das nur noch in eigenen container ja also gehen wir jetzt mal
hierhin aktuelle last projekt wenn ich hier kann weiter programmieren will ja dann mache ich nicht
hier lokal meinen idee auf oder sowas sondern ich starte einen container in dem läuft das dann alles
und die idee verbindet sich in den container gleiches gestartet das brauchen wir ein bisschen
der erste erste start beim container dauert natürlich ein bisschen aber gibt schlimmeres
So, und ich habe in diesem Container nichts drin gemountet.
Hast du ein Tutorial, wie man sowas macht oder wonach muss ich schauen?
Was meinst du?
Was sagst du zu Docker-Alternativen?
Ich bin Docker-Fanboy.
Oh, es ist expired.
Na gut, aber normalerweise würde meine Idee hier funktionieren.
Keck weh.
Und hier habe ich jetzt einen Container.
Chat.
Sekunde.
Ihr müsst mal kurz weggucken.
Ihr versprecht mir nicht hinzugucken, okay?
Kappa HD.
Okay.
Ihr habt nicht hingeguckt, richtig?
Zack.
Da sind wir wieder.
Zeige euch das mal kurz.
Also ich bin Docker-Fanboy.
Auf was für
alternativen spiel so an portman portman muss ich manchmal verwenden auf der
arbeit portman ist vollkommen fein kann man auch verwenden gerade portman hat ja
auch so eine docker abstraction cli also du kannst doch an befehle war sie
eins zu eins bei portman ausführen aber ich benutze weiterhin docker ansonsten
was meinst du was meinst du explizit für alternativen ich meine docker portman
Das ist das erste, was mir einfällt, ja.
Für
Container auf dem Desktop
fällt mir jetzt... Ja gut, es gibt da noch
dieses
Rancher-GUI und sowas, aber
wüsste ich ja nicht, wofür ich das brauche, ja.
Also ich bin mit Docker happy, ich bin
Docker-Fanboy, was das angeht.
Ich benutze auch auf der Arbeit im Prinzip
nur Docker, ja.
Serverseitig für
orchestrierung des komponentes am start
aber aber wie gesagt also doch gut gut einfach
Ah.
So, aber um darauf zurückzukommen.
was ich eigentlich sagen wollte.
Und zwar, ich entwickle mittlerweile nur noch in Containern.
Also ich habe das so gemacht,
wenn ich ein neues Projekt starte,
ich benutze dafür ein DevPod Fork.
Ich will das jetzt nicht so sehr ausbreiten,
weil das dauert dann wieder eine Viertelstunde.
Aber im Prinzip ist es so,
ich kann einfach in dem Projektverzeichnis einen Container starten,
der verbindet sich per SSH dann da rein
und hier habe ich alles, was ich für die jeweilige Programmiersprache brauche.
Also hier kann ich zum Beispiel dann auch sagen,
hier cargo run und solche dinge und zum entwickeln benutze ich in dem fall das
projekt nutze ich hier jet brains rovers und die haben so ein system die können
das frontend lokal laufen lassen und in einem container das idee back end
ich habe da keinen link zu weil ich mir das selbst ausgedacht habe zumindest das
hätte genau set up also wenn du willst ich kann das ich kann es mal schnell
zeigen wie das wie das funktioniert also was ich was ich dafür verwende ich also
also ich verwende nicht dass da das darf er wenn ich nicht ich verwende noch für
Für diese ganze Container-Geschichte verwende ich diesen Fork hier.
Von ihm hier.
Hier.
Diesen Fork verwende ich.
Der hat mittlerweile ein neues Projekt.
Darauf bin ich noch nicht umgestiegen.
Wollte ich mir eben auch mal angucken in nächster Zeit.
Das hier verwende ich.
Und letztendlich ist das ein Command-Line-Tool für Dev-Container-JSON. Dev-Container-JSON ist irgendwas, was sich Microsoft für Visual Studio Code ausgedacht hat. Plötzlich will ich an Visual Studio Code geknüpft sein. Und das handelt diese Geschichte für ein mit IDE starten und verbinden.
Also wenn du dir mehr dazu angucken willst, guck dir einfach mal hier die Seite von diesem DevPodFork an.
Oder guck dir vielleicht auch DevSee an, das ist das neue Projekt von dem.
Damit kannst du das machen.
Im Prinzip läuft das so.
Wenn ich hier ein Projekt habe, zum Beispiel das Rust-Projekt.
Das Wichtige ist, was hier unter DevContainer in dem Verzeichnis ist.
Der Rest ist egal.
Unterhalb von DevContainer gibt es drei wichtige Files.
es gibt ein Docker-File.
Das ist ein Docker-File
für den Dev-Container,
also den Container, in dem ich dann entwickeln kann.
Da geht es nicht darum, die Anwendung, die man entwickelt,
zu bauen, sondern den Container zu bauen,
in dem man dann die Anwendung
entwickelt. Also ich mache hier nicht wirklich
viel, ein bisschen
Tools installieren,
einen neuen User anlegen,
Vim-Defaults setzen und halt
Rust installieren.
Ups.
500 mal auf Rust geklickt
und Rust installieren und sowas. Also das ist in dem Container
und die eigentliche Magic
passiert in
DevContainer.json
In DevContainer.json sagst du
Name vom Projekt,
das Docker-File, was du benutzen willst, um den
Container zu bauen und dann kannst
du hier noch so ein paar Argumente hinzufügen.
Ich habe hier RunArgs, weil ich
USB-Devices im Container verwenden will.
Hier in DevContainer.init
das ist einfach nur drin, das ist leer, da passiert
nichts das kannst du dir sparen so also du brauchst du brauchst diese dev container jason
docker fall für den container so und was ich dann mache ist ich habe mir noch so connections
sonst krebs connection script gebaut das ist aber eigentlich auch in den rapper für der sport
das ist ein rapper für der sport also was dieses skript macht ist es gibt mir eine auswahl menü
welche idee ich verwenden will also see lion go land rider intelli jay rust rover oder wie es
code und dann nimmt einfach diese idee und führt dieses der port kommando aus und danach verbindet
sich per ssh rein okay aber hier dieses der port kommando ist das eigentlich interessante
also kannst du kannst das auch ohne probleme ohne mein skript hier machen und kannst dann einfach
sagen okay wenn du diese dateien hast idee willst du was ich wie es kaut verwenden ich hoffe es
uns richtig mit wie es code ja es guckt und schon hast du wie es kaut offen mit
ok wie es kaut von skater aus irgendwelchen gründen nicht nehmen wir mal was anderes
was ich öfters verwendet rast rover hier zum beispiel für das projekt
es geht alles es geht letztendlich alles also du meinst als idee als idee geht nur das was
der sport unterstützt und jetzt habe ich das ja ausgeführt startet startet hier gleich eine idee
mit meinem kram oder ach nee ich bin ja dumm okay das läuft noch weil ich es vorher gestartet habe
Das ist hier noch an.
Deswegen startet das jetzt hier nicht.
Guck mal hier.
Das läuft noch.
Wenn wir das jetzt aber löschen mal, den Pod.
Das kannst du alles mit DevPod machen.
Jetzt muss ich den Container neu bauen.
Rust Rover runterladen.
So, und dann geht das.
Also du kannst das alles mit DevPod steuern.
Ich habe mir halt nur so ein Connection-Skript gebaut, um das zu machen.
Also unterstützt wird, wir gucken uns mal an, bei seinem neuen Projekt.
was da alles unterstützt wird.
Features,
Docs,
ähm,
Providers?
Workspaces?
Äh,
ich weiß gar nicht.
Wie steht das hier drinnen?
Okay, also was geht ist
Visual Studio Code
Lokal Visual Studio Code im Browser
Jegliche JetBrains IDE
Oder
Per SSH direkt drauf
Oder beides
Also IDE und SSH
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen
Wenn ich DevPod
Direkt verwende, funktioniert nicht
Ich weiß nicht warum
Wenn ich mein Connection Script verwende, funzt es
Ich hab kein Schimmer warum
irgendwas. Aber du kannst
dich mit DevPod beschäftigen, dann kommst du
dahinter, wie das funktioniert und das klappt schon.
Also das ist eigentlich eine sehr clevere Variante
und was wichtig ist, meiner Meinung nach,
man sollte sich nicht einfach blind
in seinen Entwicklungscontainer,
in sein Homeverzeichnis reinmauten.
Weil wenn man mal Opfer einer Supply-Chain-
Attacke wird, eines der ersten
Sachen, die diese Dinger machen, ist,
okay, ich habe irgendwas kaputt gemacht, fragt mich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Dadurch, dass ich jetzt von Hand rumgebastelt
habe, habe ich irgendwas
irgendwas destroyed.
Ich weiß nicht genau was,
aber irgendwie startet
das nicht mehr.
Achte das verdammte Spiel, Alter.
Ich hab's irgendwie kaputt gemacht mit meinem Gebastel.
Aber vielleicht geht's jetzt.
Ja, und
eines der ersten Sachen, die
diese ganzen Supply Chain
Sachen machen, wenn man sich eingefangen hat, ist,
die klauen sich SSH-Keys
aus eurem Heimatverzeichnis.
Und dementsprechend
habt ihr die Arschkarte.
Also das heißt, mountet euch nicht so viel da rein.
Das geht...
Ey, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das
unter Windows geht, ehrlich gesagt.
Gucken wir mal.
Install. Das geht
auch wohl unter Windows.
Hab ich noch nie
ausprobiert. Kein Plastenschimmer,
wie das unter Windows funktioniert.
Theoretisch geht das unter Windows, ja.
Okay.
E-Kill.
Jetbrain. Bam.
Alles weg. So, in der Hoffnung.
Ich habe jetzt alles soweit gekillt.
Und es funktioniert jetzt wieder.
Der WSL alleine
hilft ja noch nichts, Container auszuführen.
Docker in WSL
oder irgendwie sowas dann. Keine Ahnung.
So, schauen wir mal, ob es jetzt wieder funktioniert oder ob ich es irgendwie kaputt gemacht habe.
Ach, ich weiß, woran das...
Nee, ich wollte gerade sagen, ich habe System-Updates gemacht.
Doch, das ist irgendwie kaputt. Keine Ahnung.
Aber in der Regel funktioniert das.
Ich habe jetzt irgendwas zerstört mit meinem...
...Gemastel hier.
Ah, jetzt funktioniert es. Okay.
Irgendwas hing da im Hintergrund noch.
Jetzt gibt es hier gleich IDE.
Hoffe ich.
hoffe ich oder nicht post post es funktioniert fast also wenn doch kein
wsl wird wie gesagt es geht auch über windows zumindest der riesen vorteil ist
ich habe halt lokal hier meine idee kann er drin entwickeln dauert beim ersten
start ein bisschen das liegt aber auch daran dass ich nur 80 gramm in der kiste
habe ich brauche nachher da mal ein bisschen mehr ram ein ich habe ja noch
acht gig also ich habe hier spricht ich habe hier meine idee ich kann ja alles
drin machen, was ich so machen will.
Wenn die IDE nicht
swappen müsste wie verrückt, dann wird das auch deutlich
schneller gehen.
Aber wenn das erstmal alles geladen ist,
dann geht das auch schneller.
Dann macht man beim ersten Mal auch einen Rust-Update
und sowas.
Der lädt hier halt noch.
So, dann habt ihr hier einen Container,
in dem ihr arbeiten könnt.
Und dadurch, dass nichts von eurem Home
gescheit gemountet ist. Wenn ihr euch hier jetzt
Supply Chain Attack mäßig was
einfangen. Also damit ist gemeint,
ihr
entwickelt was in Rust, in Python,
in Node.js, es ist egal was.
Dann verwendet eher Libraries,
die nicht von euch sind. Sobald das Projekt
eine gewisse Komplexität übersteigt,
paar Dependencies habt ihr immer.
Und diese Dependencies,
gerade was Node,
beziehungsweise NPM Dependencies angeht,
die sind ja in letzter Zeit, vergeht ja keine
Woche mal, wo nicht irgendwelche Dependencies
verseucht sind. Mit
Keylogger, SSH, Key-Extractor
und sonst was.
Und wenn ihr euch das Ganze einfangt, ist das
schon mal scheiße. Wenn ihr euch das
auf eure Entwicklungskiste einfangt,
wo alle eure SSH-Keys liegen,
wo ihr dann überall hinkommt, wo man
Session-Cookies von eurem Browser
abgreifen kann, ist das natürlich doppelt
beschissen. Also mich schützt das
gar nicht, oder nur zum Teil, dass
ich hier auf einem extra
Linux-PC bin und nicht auf meinem Windows-Desktop
überhaupt nicht.
Also, weil hier habe ich auch SSH-Keys
und sowas, die ich nicht geleakt haben will.
Wenn ich allerdings in einem Container
entwickle, in dem nichts drin ist,
außer das,
was ich zum
entwickeln brauche und keine SSH-Keys
oder sonst was habe, dann bin ich relativ
safe,
sofern er nicht irgendwie easy aus
dem Container escapen kann. Deswegen
monte ich in meinen Container kein
Docker-Socket, starte den nicht
privilegiert, mounte mein Heimatverzeichnis
sich rein, da ist es ein bisschen schwieriger.
Das heißt, wenn ich mir jetzt, sagen wir mal,
irgendwie so einen SSH-Key
Extractor-Ding
abgegriffen habe, der SSH-Keys
zu irgendeinem Hackerman rausschickt,
das kann er machen, aber
oder
ich habe hier nicht mehr SSH-Keys,
da kann er nichts abgreifen, weil es im Container ist.
Und wenn ich fertig, und was
auch gut ist, wenn ich
hier fertig entwickeln bin, wenn ich
sage hey, der ist gerade noch ein bisschen beschäftigt
mit Zeug im Hintergrund machen.
Der macht hier gerade, was macht
er denn eigentlich?
Hier, Cargo, irgendwelche Cargo Rust
Updates. So, und wenn ich jetzt fertig
entwickeln bin und sage, ey,
genug entwickelt für heute
oder, krach, Projekt, kein Bock mehr drauf.
Dann mache ich einfach meine IDE zu,
logge mich hier per SSH
aus und sage
DevPod Delete. Und dann
ist, zack, alles wieder
weg.
Also das Projekt, der Source Code vom Projekt ist natürlich noch da, aber der Container ist komplett weg.
Also auch falls ich mir Malware in diesem Container eingefangen hätte, ist die dann wieder weg.
Ja.
Dagegen schützt dich das natürlich nicht.
Also wenn du irgendwie ein Projekt hast, was du deployst, beziehungsweise wo du Dependencies hast, die im Deploy-Vorgang gezogen werden und dort ist eine verseuchte Version drin und die greift dir dann irgendwelche Secrets in deiner CI-Pipeline ab.
Ne, dagegen kann ich das nicht wirklich schützen.
das kenne ich nicht was ist das haben wir danach suchen ohne projekt against malicious code das
kenne ich gar nicht mal ich schon installiert npm ja okay was macht das das finde ich finde
ich dann? Block Malware
on Developer Laptops NCIS CD?
Aha.
Ah, Block Package.
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich, was das macht.
Okay.
Das ist, also
sagen wir mal, die Hoffnung
dahinter ist, dass innerhalb
der ersten 48 Stunden,
finde ich, ist eine sehr gute Idee,
innerhalb der
48 Stunden ein Supply Chain Angriff
auffällt und es wieder zurückgerollt wird.
eigentlich eine clevere idee eigentlich eine clevere idee
wird nicht so portet wird auch nicht so portet die supporten hauptsächlich python und javascript doch
was die rasch das ist würde würde mir würde mir beispielsweise für mein rast projekt gar
nichts bringen und für mein .NET Projekt
und für mein Go Projekt auch nicht.
Was ist eigentlich RushX?
NPM, okay, irgendein
JavaScript-Gedöns. Würde mir beispielsweise
gar nichts bringen. Bin ich aber trotzdem
eine coole Sache.
Cargo kann das nicht.
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob es da schon...
Ey, ich wette mit euch, die Rust-Fanboys
waren schon am Start und haben
Issue gemacht für Cargo Support.
Natürlich.
Was sonst?
Eine W ago.
One week ago. Okay, verstehe.
War grad Brain Lag.
Jo. Also ich finde,
da ist das, man kann
das ja kombinieren. Es schadet ja nix.
Du kannst ja ohne Probleme so eine
DevPod-Geschichte plus
das hier kombinieren. Weil umso
besser, wenn du dir gar nichts einfängst.
Wenn du dir doch was einfängst, müssen die Leute
erstmal aus dem Container raus.
Also wie gesagt, ein paar Sachen würde
ich nicht machen. Nämlich
hier.
Ihr habt ihre Dev-Container. Ich würde
nicht auf die Idee kommen, hier
mehr zu mounten, als es unbedingt
sein muss. Also hier jetzt zu sagen,
mounte mir mal
mein
komplettes Home und
DevDocker-Socket oder wie das heißt.
Das ist eine ziemlich dumme Idee.
Weil dann haben die direkten Zugriff auf eure ganzen SSH-Keys im Home.
Und ihr habt einen Docker-Socket.
Und ihr wisst, wie es ist.
Sobald ihr einen Docker-Socket habt, seid ihr gut.
Und dann auch nicht mit SSH reingehen.
Warum nicht?
Mit SSH-A reingehen.
Was macht der?
Ach, Agent.
Du meinst, dass du nicht deine SSH-Credentials mitnimmst.
Ja, das ist vielleicht auch eine sinnvolle Sache.
Mache ich ja auch nicht.
Ich nehme auch keine NTS-Sachen mit.
Weil ich logge mich von da ja eh nirgendwo per SSH ein.
Das ist ja wirklich rein zum Entwickeln, dass die IDE läuft.
Die Anwendung bauen selber, das läuft dann hier beispielsweise über so ein Docker-File hier.
Aber da bin ich natürlich auch für Supply Chain Angriff nicht.
Nicht sicher.
Also sobald, das muss ich vielleicht nochmal sagen,
sobald ihr
Sobald ihr in einem Container
selbst wiederum
den Docker-Socket vom Host
reingemautet habt,
oder generell,
sobald, man kann es egal sagen,
sobald ihr Docker-Access
habt, habt ihr
Root-Access, wenn es kein Rootless-Docker
ist ja diese standard geschichte ist ist so
kann euch das auch zeigen ich hoffe ich krieg's jetzt aus dem kopf richtig hin
ja also ihr könnt zum beispiel sagen docker ran war mal so was hier wie war
das minus V slash nach
äh, slash blub.
So, und guck mal hier, was hier unter
minus slash V hängt.
Äh, slash, was hier unter slash blub
hängt. Und da slash blub hängt
mein komplettes Root-Verzeichnis
von meiner
Host-Kiste. Ja?
Ich, blub,
war Docker, oder war
äh, run
Docker, sogar da
sogar das Docker-Socket. Das heißt, ich könnte
von dort jetzt weitere, ich bin jetzt im Container,
könnte ich
jetzt weitere Docker-Container starten.
Oder aber, ich könnte
das Root-Passwort ändern auch und solche
Geschichten. Also das funktioniert.
Ich könnte jetzt ein
chroot
beispielsweise machen.
Nach blub. So. Und jetzt
bin ich, guck mal,
ich bin jetzt als Root
auf meinem Host-System.
Einfach nur, weil
ich Rechte habe, einen Docker-Container zu starten.
Also Docker für sich genommen ist auch nicht ungefährlich.
Also guck mal, ich weiß nicht, ob man das jetzt nachvollziehen konnte, aber ich bin Max, ich bin nicht Root.
Aber sobald ich die Möglichkeit habe, als Max einen Docker-Container zu starten, bin ich faktisch Root.
Wie gesagt, zumindest wenn man das standardmäßig so betreibt, wie das mit Docker ist, dass man Docker-Demon als Root laufen hat.
Das ist so. Also sobald ihr Docker-Container-Rechte habt, habt ihr Root-Rechte auf der Kiste.
Das heißt, es ist natürlich auch wichtig, dass wenn ihr in einem Container was isolieren wollt,
dass der Container selbst wiederum keine Rechte hat, Docker-Container zu starten,
weil sonst ist der Ausbruch aus dem Container easy as fuck.
So.
So schaut's aus.
Deswegen finde ich das sogar eine richtig gute Kombination, wenn man das beides macht.
Also dieses Projekt kannte ich noch nicht, ich finde das Projekt richtig cool.
Wenn man beispielsweise Node.js Sachen entwickelt, wäre es ja durchaus sinnvoll, diesen Proxy zu verwenden.
Plus Dev Pods und dann ist man relativ safe. Man ist nicht komplett safe, aber man ist relativ safe.
safe.
Finde ich
eigentlich ganz gut.
So, Chat. Ich hoffe, man konnte das Ganze
jetzt halbwegs nachvollziehen.
Ja, manchmal wird ein bisschen sidetracked.
Ist da Potman nicht deutlich besser?
Ja.
Also, wenn du es rootless
laufen lässt, ja.
Die Rootrechte kommen durch den Docker-Demon.
Ja, man kann Docker auch rootless laufen lassen,
aber standardmäßig ist das so,
dass Docker-Rechte bekommst
du dadurch dass du in der docker gruppe bist weil die docker gruppe hier hat war
doch das socket cook da hat die docker gruppe zugriff drauf und alle user die
in der docker gruppe sind kann das machen und der docker die man selbst
läuft als gut der darf alles und effekt hast du dann dadurch gut hier übrigens
beide weh auch ohne passwort ihr braucht keine rechte krebs docker ihr doch ad
läuft als gut
keine ahnung ob man das kann
so sieht's aus
excellent next
wir sind hart gesitrackt
ist übrigens auch eine beliebte übung zum beispiel auf set servers
wie kommst du hier an root rechte
du hast keine sudo rechte
aber du hast die möglichkeit docker container zu starten
So, schauen wir mal.
Was können wir uns denn hier für schöne Videos
angucken heute?
I've underrated CLI
Tools.
Okay, ich bin skeptisch
bei solchen Videos,
weil
solche Videos immer die gleichen
Tools zeigen.
Aber was hat der hier denn zum Beispiel?
Oh, guck mal, das sind Tools, die kenne ich gar nicht.
Leaf,
GH Crab, Lazy
Air Sync, Tuxedo und Kek W.
Ne, Kevin.
Wieso das Video Type Stamps hat?
Der ist halt sehr korrekt hier.
Wir scrollen da mal kurz durch. So Videos gucke
ich mega gerne.
Neue CLI-Tools
sind immer Pogu.
Das Auer-Video. Ja,
können wir dann immer noch machen.
Ich habe die IT meiner Firma nachgebaut, aber kostenlos.
Schön.
Alte Hardware mitgenommen auf der Arbeit, oder was?
Der Vergleich VMware vs. Open Source.
Naja, gut.
Im Business-Umfeld würde ich sagen, ist VMware halt immer noch ziemlich gesetzt.
Aber schauen wir mal, was gibt es denn für andere RAID-CLI-Tools?
Terminal Experience more enjoyable.
Okay, wir scrollen mal
ab, das ist schon immer, wir scrollen mal ein bisschen vor.
Also was ist Leaf?
All the systems. So instead of time.
Leaf is a powerful Markdown-Previewer
for your Terminal with features like
live reloading, beautiful Markdown-Renders
and so much more.
Alter, der hat sich aber auch Mühe gegeben, besonders lustlos
zu reden, oder?
Okay, es ist ein Markdown-
Viewer für Bash.
An sich nice,
okay, verstehe ich.
Aber wenn ich Markdown lese, muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich lese Markdown immer nicht als Markdown
in der Shell.
Also wenn wir jetzt hier einen Markdown-File haben, legen wir mal eins an hier, keine Ahnung,
blub.md, ja, hier
0, 1,
2, so, Markdown-File.
Ich lese das in der
Shell immer halt
mit Syntax-Highlighting im WIMP
als Plaintext
Ach, readme.md
haben wir ja. Ja, na gut, da steht aber halt
auch genauso wenig drin. Da steht Raspba.
Ne, also ich lese das mit
Syntax-Highlighting in der Shell als Plaintext
und wenn ich es gerendert
lesen will, ja, dann mache
ich es halt in Visual Studio Code
auf
und sage hier
Preview oder
Markdown
Preview.
So.
Ob ich da jetzt einen Markdown
Reader
in der Shell brauche?
Mal Exempel. Max?
Ich
klau mir mal die Readme aus deinem Projekt.
Ich brauche eine Readme, wo ordentlich was drin steht.
So, excellent.
We get.
Also ich lese die Readme normalerweise hier so auf dem Terminal.
Im Terminal mit WIM.
Ja, man hat hier Syntax Highlighting drin.
Das checkt er übrigens gar nicht.
Ich muss das umbenennen.
Readme 1 MD in Readme MD.
Jetzt mache ich es auf und jetzt checkt das WIM.
So, ich lese das eigentlich plaintext hin mit Syntax Highlighting. Ich finde, das ist auch vollkommen okay. Mein Wim ist ziemlich am abkacken hier mit diesen Unicode Zeichen. Woran liegt denn das? Habe ich hier Noto Fonts nicht installiert? Doch.
ähm
hab ich
Dings nicht installiert
äh wie heißt diese
wie heißt diese
OnFamily
für
asiatische Zeichen und sowas
ähm
mit
hier Adobe Sans
Adobe Source
genau die haben viele die haben viele hier genau abt eigentlich abt
kann man da nicht sagen hier
korean japanese symbols
Kann ich ja nicht sagen.
Ich will 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12 installieren.
13, 14, 15.
Okay, bam.
Ne, bin ich mitbekommen.
Hoffen wir mal, ob das Readme jetzt besser funktioniert, wenn ich die ganzen Fonts installiere.
1 bis 15.
Ja.
Hätte ich gewusst, dass ich 1 bis 15 installieren will?
Oh.
Download failed.
So, mal gucken, ob jetzt die Readme besser aussieht.
Nö.
Okay, mein Terminal ist zu schlecht.
Wie sollte die Readme denn eigentlich aussehen?
Ach, das sind Flags.
Moment, warum funktionieren keine Emoji...
Das sind Emoji-Flex, oder?
Warum funktionieren denn keine Emoji-Flex?
Aber ich hab doch Emoji-Flex.
Geh um Emoji...
Ah!
Guck mal, irgendwie...
Irgendwie sind die Flex...
Sind die Flex kaputt bei mir im Terminal?
Warum auch immer? Komisch
Vielleicht liegt es auch am Wim
Ah, es liegt am Wim
Es liegt am Wim
Im normalen Terminal ist das alles okay
Okay, also zumindest
Ich lese, da wären wir schon dabei
Dass ein Markdown wieder im Terminal gar nicht so verkehrt ist
So, also normalerweise lese ich eben Markdown hier
Wenn ich den Plaintext haben will, halt den Plaintext im Wim
und wenn ich es in irgendeiner Form gerendert
haben will, mache ich es halt in
Visual Studio Code auf
und sage hier
Markdown Review.
Aber ich sehe
schon, so doll ist das.
Na gut, das ist es ja.
Und wie wäre das mit Leaf?
Ist das mit Leaf besser?
Gibt es das überhaupt
hier in den Standard-Repos?
Ne, gibt es gar nicht.
Guck mal, das sind
Underrated Tools
GitHub Leaf Markdown
Tatsächlich, richtig
Underrated Tool
Mit 1,9k Stern
Rust
Natürlich
Die Bilder gehen nicht, weil ich das nicht ausgecheckt habe
Ja, ich weiß
Hat der kein
Hour Packages
NPM natürlich, Cargo
Ach, Leaf Markdown Viewer, da ist er doch.
Okay, gibt es tatsächlich.
Naja.
Da bin ich noch, weiß ich nur nicht, ob ich das...
Max, ich benutze dann mal weiter dein Repo für das auszuprobieren.
Ja, gut.
Das, okay.
Ich gette, ich gette es.
Ich gette es, dass es gar nicht so verkehrt ist,
einen Markdown-Viewer im Terminal zu haben.
Ja, ansonsten muss man die Sachen hier öffnen
in Visual Studio Code.
Visual Studio Code hat keinen Bock da drauf,
das zu rendern.
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Die Bilder müssten doch hier auch liegen.
Ich glaube, Visual Studio Code ist einfach zu dumm dafür, oder?
Okay, dann installieren wir doch mal Leaf.
Gucken wir mal, ob Leaf das besser kann.
Leaf Markdown Viewer.
Schauen wir mal.
Schauen wir mal, ob Leaf das besser macht.
Yes.
Leaf.
Read Me MD.
Oh.
Ups.
Blazingly Fast, written in Rust, Leute.
Leaf, kack bei deiner Readme ab.
Du hast es zerstört.
Tja, dann war es das wohl mit Leaf.
Es ist zu Blazingly Fast.
Vielleicht, vielleicht, warte mal.
War das überhaupt?
Guck mal, das ist eine uralte Version.
Leaf Markdown.
Viewer.
Guck mal hier.
Das ist Leaf.
Das ist uralt.
1, 2, 8.
Wann ist denn das?
Ach, das ist Upsnap
Das ist das falsche Repo
Ich war im falschen
Ich war im falschen Repo, okay
Okay, 1, 2, 8 ist tatsächlich das Neueste
Ich hab nix gesagt
Tja, Leute
Lief, kackt, kackt ab
cargo install okay wir kompilieren das selbst drei stunden später
guck mal hier rast braucht immer ewig bis da was gebildet ist übrigens was mega geiles was cargo
ich weiß nicht wie cargo das macht guck mal cargo kann progress progress im mod rennern in in die
Terminal Tabs.
Ist das nicht
POG?
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert, wenn ich
selbst From Master
installe.
Wobei, ist ja gar nicht From Master.
Vor zwei, two weeks hat er zuletzt
submitted.
Ja, okay, mein Rechner ist ein bisschen ausgelastet durch das Rust-Kompilieren.
Ich geb's ja zu.
Der Browser ist ganz schön am Abscheißen gerade.
Bei voll ausgelastetem Rechner.
Alter, okay.
Leute.
Der hat ein paar Probleme gerade.
Und er hat auch ein bisschen wenig RAM.
Ach, guck mal, hier hat er gefixt.
Hier hat er gefixt.
Das ist bestimmt das Problem.
Wir müssen es, Leute, wir müssen es
from master, from main
müssen wir es kompilieren.
Bam.
Gleich ist es
Wir haben es nicht from main.
Wir haben es jetzt 1, 2, 8.
Leaf.
Read me MD.
Okay, das ist broken.
Also, gibt es so etwas wie
Cargo remove leaf oder so?
Äh, uninstall?
Ne, wie war das? Wie habe ich das überhaupt installiert?
Cargo install?
Und jetzt kann ich...
Was ist das Gegenteil?
Uninstall?
Okay, ja. Also wir müssen tatsächlich das Projekt from head compilern, weil sonst ist das verbuggt und geht nicht.
Wir könnten natürlich auch ein älteres Release nehmen, aber das machen wir nicht.
Äh, tja, Cargo-Build vielleicht einfach so?
Jawoll! Bam, drei Stunden später.
Also man muss ja, Rust muss man ja eins sagen, so cool die Sprache ist, die Compile-Times sind krass lang.
Aber das liegt auch daran, weil die immer Milliarden Dependencies haben und...
Die haben ja fast schon sowas wie einen Is-Odd-Is-Even-Ähnlichkeit, ne?
Schauen wir mal.
Leave.
Wo hat er das jetzt hin kopiert?
Target.
Debug.
Leave.
Okay, schauen wir mal, ob es jetzt geht.
Read me.
Aha.
Okay.
Dann, Max, dann lesen wir mal deine.
Read me.
Okay.
Die Bilder gehen nicht.
by the way. Max, hast du eine Idee,
warum die Bilder nicht gehen?
Lokal? Die Bilder sind doch im Asset-Folder, oder?
Assets. Die Markdown-Reader
lokal sind da, glaube ich, einfach zu blöd für.
Das ist Leaf-Ischi. Aber
GitHub, ne?
Vielleicht muss ich ja auch,
weil das ja relativ ist,
vielleicht muss ich auch hier in das Verzeichnis
rein. Weil, guck, die
die Bilder sind ja
Ah!
Kann das sein, wegen Slash Assets, dass er das nicht checkt?
Dass er da gucken muss?
Oh, hier.
Leave.
Target.
Debug.
Äh, wir sind gerade etwas sidetracked.
Okay, die Bilder funktionieren nicht.
Mich würde halt echt interessieren, ob Bilder funktionieren, ne?
Mich würde wirklich interessieren, ob Bilder funktionieren, weil...
Hat Leave Image, Image Support?
Image? Das hat kein Image Support.
Das wäre halt mega nice, hätte es noch Image Support.
Mach doch mal ein Slash weg.
Okay, gute Idee.
Read me.
Wir können auch einfach sagen, Punkt, Punkt Slash.
Okay.
ne, juckt es nicht
juckt es nicht
würde es denn
Visual Studio Codes checken, wenn da
.slash drin steht
ups, äh, oh, geht das
agent kacke, geh weg
ok, wenn man .slash
macht, checkt
das Visual Studio Code
also, leave kann keine
Images. Naja,
dann weiß ich ja nicht.
Dann weiß ich ja nicht, ob das so sinnig ist.
So, das war jetzt
das erste Geheimtipp
aus dem Video.
Erster Geheimtipp lief.
Also ich bin nicht so sehr davon überzeugt,
dass ich einen CLI
Markdown
Viewer brauche.
Deswegen
Skippen wir das mal.
Was haben wir als nächstes?
GH-Crap.
Ist das GitHub, oder was?
Ja.
Das Problem kenne ich.
Und wisst ihr, was ein Problem bei GitHub ist?
wenn man, wenn man, wenn man, ups,
Moment, Moment, ich bin dumm, falsch
geklickt, zack, so. Das ist ja das
Problem bei GitHub, ist, wenn man sowas runterladen
will. Ja, also sagen wir mal, ich will mir
jetzt hier dieses Image runterladen
oder, oder keine Ahnung, ich will mir jetzt, nehmen wir was anderes.
Ich will mir jetzt hier das
Readme runterladen. Wenn ich jetzt einfach nur hier
so mache,
wenn ich jetzt einfach nur sage, hier
we get,
dann
downloadet er das HTML-Dokument
und nicht das eigentliche, was ich haben will.
Das ist so ein Ding, das
fuckt mich schon ewig ab auf GitHub.
Aber das ist tatsächlich ein Problem.
Man muss dann hier immer auf Raw klicken
und den Link kann man dann runterladen.
Es ist aber ein bisschen nervig.
Gab es hier mal Subs? Die Leute haben alle gerade
kein Geld. In Zeiten, wo
Eiskugeln 2 Euro kosten.
Holt euch lieber
Eis, anstatt
zu subscriben.
Aber was ihr
machen könnt, wenn euch der Stream gefällt, was mich
auch
richtig freut,
ist, wenn ihr mir followt.
Falls ihr mich gefollowt habt.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, was mich mindestens genauso
freut, aber da würde ich
ja die Leute aktiv davon
abraten zu subscriben.
Das will ich natürlich auch nicht.
Aber ich krieg mal ganz coole Emotes, wenn ihr subscribed habt.
Aber ich freu mich auch über Follows.
Das Beste, was ihr machen könnt,
da kriegt ihr auch immer eine Nachricht, wenn der Stream online geht.
Fall nicht, ihr könnt auch rausschalten, falls euch auf den Sack geht.
Aber Follows freu ich mich auch immer sehr.
Ja, das Problem habe ich auch öfters.
Ist es denn auch Blazingly Fast written in Rust?
Sorry, nicht Blazingly Fast, Laserspeed Fast written in Rust.
Aha.
Browse die Repo zuerst und dann hol genau das, was du willst.
excellent! sorry, laser speed fast! gibt es das denn auf... ah ja, gibt es hier auch schon mal als
our package? aber wir können es auch cargo installen, pip installen geht auch, nix installen geht auch
BTF. Ich habe sogar
nix drauf. Habe ich nicht?
Oh, Leute.
Kein nix am Start.
Das müssen wir
aber gleich nachholen.
A W
Chat, warum braucht nix
ähm, AWS
Libraries? Fragezeichen.
Egal.
Who cares?
Was?
Okay, Nix funktioniert natürlich immer.
Nix Feature is disabled.
Add extra experimental
features Nix Command.
WTF?
Moment, muss ich das jetzt als Sudo run?
Okay, Nix ist einfach
zu high IQ für mich.
Das ist zu
high IQ. Warte mal, Nix Env
musste man doch machen, oder?
Run? Okay, keine Ahnung. Ohne Scheiß, Leute, nix ist einfach zu massive für mich.
Installieren wir das einfach mal so.
Zack, zack, zack.
Was ist das eigentlich für eine geile, bunte Fahrtübersicht?
Äh, du meinst das da?
Das ist mein Prompt.
Mein Prompt ist zweizeilig.
Das hier neben kannst du knicken.
Die Uhrzeit interessiert eigentlich keinen.
Mein Prompt ist zweizeilig, weil ich der Meinung bin,
dass zweizeiliger Prompt einfach superior ist gegenüber einzeiligem Prompt.
Weil du hast halt immer die gleiche Stelle, wo der Cursor anfängt.
Das ist Starship.
starship dass die starship konflikt dafür sind die sonderzeichen drin die
man terminal nicht darstellen kann oder war jetzt habe starship das da
kannst du ziemlich gut customizen es ist nicht viel customer ist ein bisschen
customer ist bist du zufrieden mit cash us ja ich habe vorher jahrelang in
selbst installiertes Arch verwendet und seitdem ich mir so ein Linux Mini PC hier gekauft habe,
wie gesagt, das ist nicht der fetteste, fetteste Kiste, ich habe mir so ein extra Linux Mini PC
gekauft zum Basteln und Streamen, also Linux Sachen da drauf machen, streamen und ich wollte
halt auch was Wayland basiertes verwenden. Wayland kann man halt in der VM komplett vergessen und da
habe ich mir gedacht, ey komm, warum nicht mal CacheOS ausprobieren und ich muss sagen, vollkommen
fein kdk de ist jeder einzig ernst zu nehmen desktop auf linux meiner meinung
nach ihr wisst dass ich genau bescheuert finde und teiling window manager bin ich
kein großer teiling window manager fern ich habe selbst jahrelang teiling window
manager benutzt auch jahre lang wo ich schon gestreamt habe aber das ist halt
nichts für mainstream in dem mainstream leuten kannst du nicht mit teiling
window manager kommen deswegen bin ich ja ein das ist kde ist der einzige
ernst zu nehmende desktop unter linux und ich benutze den ja wie einen teiling
window manager ich habe kde genommen weil kde default
vorschlag ist bzw plasma muss man eigentlich sagen dass die voll
vorschlagbar cash us ist und ich sehe das ja ich benutze das wie ein teiling
window manager full screen browser full screen full screen terminal full screen
Chaterino hier und geteilt wird
im Terminal.
XFC?
XFC geht auch.
XFC ist okay, wobei ich XFC
nicht
wirklich als ernstzunehmende
Mainstream-Desktop nehme. Erstens ist es
aktuell, glaube ich, noch X-Only oder hat noch
ziemlich viele Probleme unter Wayland.
Und das ist bei weitem
nicht so umfangreich wie
KDE. Du hast zum Beispiel
und XFC hast du noch nicht mal eine
Ländereinstellungen für das Format
deiner Uhrzeit und sowas.
Äh, nee, für das Format der
Woche im Kalender und sowas.
Also, aber XFCE ist an sich
ist es zwar kein ernstzunehmender,
ich sag mal, richtiger Mainstream-Desktop.
Ich benutze ihn auf der Arbeit, weil er leichtgewichtig
ist und vorinstalliert
daherkommt, aber
im Prinzip
so eine
komplett umfassende Desktop-Lösung,
die alles drin hat,
auch ein bisschen customisable ist und so gibt es meiner Meinung nach und bedienbar ist für die meisten Leute, gibt es meiner Meinung nach nur KDE.
Und wie gesagt, das sage ich als Tiling Window Manager Fan.
Mit Gnome konnte ich noch nie was anfangen.
Mit Gnome konnte ich noch nie was anfangen. Gnome hat ja zum Beispiel noch nicht mal einen minimieren Button für Fenster.
Standardmäßig.
Da ist der Ex-Windows-User erstmal komplett aufgeschmissen.
Ich weiß nicht, was HCI Design ist.
Könnte das sein, dass das damit gemeint ist für Leute mit Handicap?
Da soll ja Gnome wirklich nicht übel sein.
Ansonsten kann ich Gnome nicht verwenden. Ich kriege Anfälle, wenn ich Gnome verwenden muss.
Fancy Begriffe UX.
Ich werde das grausam untergenommen.
Die Bedienweise ist richtig eklig.
Ich komme damit überhaupt nicht klar.
Ja, und deswegen, ich bin mit Cache echt zufrieden.
Ich wollte es eigentlich nur mal ausprobieren.
Weil ich mir gedacht habe,
bevor du Arch jetzt von Hunter drauf installierst
und alles selbst einrichtest,
probiere nochmal CacheOS mit Plasma aus.
Habe ich installiert.
habe ich für gut befunden.
Und es hat zwei
Features, die ich auch ziemlich gut finde,
wie sie voreingestellt sind. Nämlich,
sobald du was installierst, ja,
wir installieren jetzt hier mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
A-Top habe ich zwar schon installiert,
aber jetzt können wir einfach nochmal A-Top installieren, okay.
Nochmal, doppelt installieren,
hilft besser. Dann seht ihr, der macht
einen Snapshot. Das heißt, wenn ich
jetzt mein System schrotte
und es nicht mehr bootet,
kann ich einfach im Bootmanager
noch. Zurückrollen auf den alten
Stand. Sehr gutes Feature.
Sehr schön, dass das standardmäßig installiert ist.
Funktioniert richtig gut, nur mit
BTFS zusammen. Aber
kommt halt defaultmäßig so. Finde ich nice.
Sehr gut. Und das zweite
Feature, was für mich,
wenn ich KDE verwende, unverzichtbar
ist, Leute.
Wobbly Windows.
Debian ist mir zu outdated.
Leute, Wobbly Windows, das ist mit Abstand einfach das wichtigste Feature ever.
Wer kein Wobbly Windows hat, verpasst wirklich was.
Gibt es Leute, die Wobbly Windows wirklich nutzen und mögen?
Eher gefragt, gibt es wirklich Leute, die das nicht mögen?
Wobbly Windows ist doch ernsthaft das Beste, was es gibt.
Wobbly Windows, Alter.
Hör ich da...
Was?
Das ist das Beste.
Guck mal hier, wie geil das Wobbeln, Alter.
Guck mal hier.
Wobbel, wobbel, wobbel, wobbel, wobbel, wobbel, wobbel.
Oh, jetzt habe ich es irgendwie kaputt gemacht.
Beste.
Also ich kann nicht verstehen, wie man das nicht mögen kann.
Ich sehe es wenig, weil ich die Sachen immer im Fullscreen laufen habe.
Aber wenn ich mal was moven muss, dann muss es wobbeln.
Wie lernt man am besten mit KI?
Keine Ahnung, was ich da drauf jetzt sagen soll.
also ich, okay, keine Ahnung, ich habe jetzt nicht den Anspruch drauf, dass das irgendwie das Beste ist, wie man es macht.
Also ich kann nicht sagen, wie ich das benutze.
Also wenn ich beispielsweise was programmieren will und davon keine Ahnung habe, zum Beispiel was in Rust, da habe ich nicht wirklich viel Plan von,
dann programmiere ich erstmal drauf los und wenn es dann Sachen gibt, die ich nicht verstehe,
beziehungsweise Sachen, die funktionieren, ich mir aber denke, ah, das kann man ein bisschen schöner machen,
dann gebe ich ganz gerne mal den Code
meiner KI und sage, ey, kann man das
schöner machen oder siehst du hier irgendwelche
Logikfehler oder sowas drin und lass
mir das dann von der KI erklären
ich finde, da lernt man ganz gut was bei
weil man da auch viele Sachen sieht
die man noch nicht kannte, ja
oder was auch gut ist, wofür ich
KI auch ganz sinnvoll finde, ist
zu sagen, ey, ich weiß wie man XYZ
in Go macht, so und so
erklär mir mal, wie man das in C Sharp
oder in Rust oder sonst was macht
dafür ist das auch ganz praktisch
was nichts bringt ist meiner meinung nach komplett ist vibe coden also du du du du
copy paste ist quasi nur noch aus der ki oder vibe code und vibe code ist ja auch heutzutage
hat man das ja agentic engineering also du copy paste ist nicht mehr was du lässt lässt es das
für dich machen der letzte nicht wirklich was bei und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen rein vibe
codete projekte die sind immer sehr verbose zu lesen ja also kd ich schwätze
nicht kate kate kate schwätzt halt nicht nur in readme ist richtig rum sondern
schwätzt halt auch in source code richtig rum
aber an sich so zur unterstützung während man selbst was programmiert wenn
ich das finde ich das nice und da lernt man auch viel bei und ansonsten ich weiß nicht was die
beste variante ist ki zu benutzen wahrscheinlich ist die beste variante wahrscheinlich ist die
beste variante ki zu benutzen sehr individuell wann glaubst du programmiert die ki nun auch selber
das wird noch lange dauern.
Also
du musst der KI schon ordentliche
Vorgaben und Architekturvorgaben machen,
dass
so
Agentic-Vibe-Coding-Gedöns zu sinnvollen
Ergebnissen führt.
Und auch dann verbrätst du ordentlich
Tokens.
also wenn man schnell irgendwie mal so einen Prototyp entwickeln will,
so nach dem Motto, so könnte es aussehen,
und du dir einen ordentlichen Prompt aus den Fingern saugen kannst,
wobei ja die Pros mittlerweile nicht mehr selbst prompten,
die benutzen eine KI, um eine andere KI zu prompten.
Das ist ja so der Trend.
Also man erklärt einer KI, was man will, und sagt, mach mir einen Prompt raus,
und den Prompt fütterst du dann an Cloud Code oder irgendwas und lässt es dann machen.
Also ja, dafür ist es ganz gut, aber meiner Meinung nach ist die beste Variante tatsächlich die Kombination aus
ich programmiere und benutze KI zur Ergänzung.
Für meinen Geschmack kommt da das Beste bei raus.
aber dass die wirklich komplett alleine so nach dem motto lk ich bräuchte ein
programm für mein nächstes business und ich habe die business idee xy
also ich glaube das wird noch einige jahre jahrzehnte wenn überhaupt dauern
Wie ist der Einsatz bei euch im Unternehmen?
Ich finde, die machen das gut bei uns.
Also, wir haben mehrere Varianten, was KI angeht.
Wir haben für so den niedrigen Einstieg, haben wir einen internen Chat.
Ja?
Da kannst du reingehen und Models auswählen.
Wir haben Models.
Wir haben das neueste GPT.
Wir haben das neueste Opus.
Da drinne.
Fable haben wir glaube ich nicht.
Heißt das jetzt Mythos oder Fable?
Ah, ich blick da nicht durch.
Aber wir haben da ganz gute Models in dem Chat.
Und das ist halt ganz nice.
Das ist auch überall verlinkt.
Also, die Models dort haben auch Anwendungen bei uns ans Sharepoint und an die Wikis und sowas. Das ist wirklich ganz praktisch. Ja, wenn jetzt jemand sich nicht so sehr damit beschäftigt, kann er einfach den Chat aufmachen und sagen, ey, guck mal, gab es da nicht letztens eine News zum Thema XY?
und dann spuckt die KI die aktuellen, die bestmatchenden News aus, aus dem Wiki oder ja, man kann auch bei der KI ganz gut fragen, ey, guck mal hier, ich habe hier einen YAML-File und copy-paste es rein, irgendwo hier ist ein Fehler drin, also so für den niedrigen Einstieg haben wir einen Chat, das finde ich auch sehr gut gemacht und den benutze ich bei uns auch tatsächlich recht oft.
So, dann haben wir noch verschiedene andere Sachen. Wir haben noch für Office 365 gibt es noch Copilot, haben wir noch am Start. Der kann auch Sharepoint Sachen machen, Word Dokumente editieren und Gedöns. Benutze ich persönlich nie. Ich habe das in der Testphase noch ein bisschen benutzt, benutze ich eigentlich nie.
Seitdem wir das neueste GPT bei uns im Chat haben, brauche ich Copilot nicht.
Und ihr wisst, ich mache eh einen großen Bogen um Office-Dokumente.
Also insofern, das brauche ich nicht.
So, und dann haben wir noch Gemini Agent CLI oder so, wie das heißt.
Das musst du dir aber beantragen.
Da brauchst du eine extra Workstation für.
Habe ich.
Habe ich euch ja erzählt.
Ich habe jetzt einen kompletten Linux-Desktop auf der Arbeit.
Gott sei Dank wieder.
und da kann man Gemini CLI verwenden
und das als
Agentic Coding Plattform benutzen
haben wir ein paar Leute
im Team, die schwören da
voll drauf
ich hab's installiert, ich muss euch ehrlich
sagen, so oft benutze ich's
nicht, ich benutze es hauptsächlich
für Readme's
so ey, ich hab hier zwei neue
Environment Variablen hinzugefügt
update mir mal die Readme
ja, dafür benutze ich das
für größere Programmier-Sachen so
bau mir mal das und das und das und das ein
weniger.
Ist aber sehr unterschiedlich.
Wir haben welche im Team, die haben komplette
Ansible-Überwachungs-Web-Interfaces
irgendwie in Gemini
da wipe-coded.
Bei uns ist eher das Problem,
dass glaube ich die Leute zu viel Talkings verbrauchen.
das das das gab es in zwei zwei phasen am anfang war das so du konntest bei uns im chat unserem
internen chat tool konntest du auswählen ja konnte auswählen gemini gpt opus weiß nicht was wir sonst
noch so haben alle gleichberechtigt nebeneinander konnte einfach auswählen mittlerweile haben sie
das so gemacht, neben den Models ist ein Dollarzeichen.
Dollarzeichen,
ein Dollarzeichen, zwei Dollarzeichen oder drei
Dollarzeichen. Dass die Leute
zumindest, wenn sie anklicken, schon mal
das Gefühl dafür haben, wie viel kostet
denn das jeweilige Model. Opus
hat drei Dollarzeichen daneben.
Trotzdem nehme ich immer Opus, weil Opus für die Aufgaben,
die ich da habe,
war es so technisch gesagt eigentlich das einfach beste
von dem, was wir im Chat haben.
Und das nächste
ist, ich habe auch schon gelesen,
dass angeblich jetzt geplant ist, dass nicht mehr alle Models für alle Leute zugänglich sind.
Also dass man Opus nur noch für Leute in der IT freischalten möchte.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es zu teuer ist.
Einfach mal gucken. Ist nicht mein Problem.
Versicherungsgelds, die haben genug Geld.
By the way, wollten wir uns nicht das Tool hier eigentlich angucken?
Und ich wurde jetzt ein wenig sidetracked.
Beziehungsweise wurde ich nicht seit 3,5 Stunden schon sidetracked.
Am Ende zahlen es die Kunden ja noch klar.
Denkst du, so eine Kiste wäre gut für Homelab als Einstieg?
Lenovo Sync
Center
Mini PC mit Intel Core
Hey
Fast den gleichen habe ich hier in meinem
Stream Vorschau Rechner
8700K ist da drin
Also die CPU hat schon einige Jahre
Auf dem Buckel, aber reicht immer noch
Hat aber glaube ich
Nur 4 Kerne
Fragezeichen, ich gucke mal kurz bei mir
In Task Manager
Oder?
Äh, sieht man gar nicht.
Kors.
Sechs Kerne hat die. Sechs Kerne.
Ja, eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Sechs Kerne. Da war es verkehrt.
Äh, 16 G Gramm.
Ja, damit kannst du schon
was anfangen. Also,
SSDs sind aktuell
teuer. Pascal, bist du
überhaupt noch da, bevor ich jetzt lange rumlabere?
Egal, ich sag trotzdem was zu.
Also, an sich klingt das von den Specs her schon mal nicht
verkehrt für Homelab. Das Ding
ist nur, brauchst du Erweiterbarkeit.
Also brauchst du PC-Express-
Slots zum Beispiel, die wirst
du ja in diesen Dingern, in den Mini-PCs
eher weniger finden. Brauchst du SATA-
Anschlüsse, hast keine Möglichkeit,
Mini-PC-Festplatten reinzumachen, gescheit
mehrere. Also
was Erweiterbarkeit angeht,
ist so ein Mini-PC
eher jetzt nicht das Beste.
Also wenn du dir nass bauen willst und sagst,
ey, ich brauche sechs Einschübe,
fünf Einschübe, drei, vier Einschübe
für Festplatten, dann ist das nix. Dann wirst du im Endeffekt bei externen USB-Festplatten landen.
Das funktioniert auch. Man muss aber sagen, dass das prinzipiell ein bisschen unzuverlässiger ist,
externe USB-Festplatten. Erstens hast du da das Problem, dass du relativ schnell die Platte
abziehen kannst. Und das zweite ist, dass USB-Latenzen ein bisschen unberechenbarer sind
als nvm oder sata ansonsten und und natürlich sparst du auch wenig platz
weil ob du dir jetzt eine ordentliche ordentliche fette nasskiste kaufs mit
einschub wechselrahmen oder mini pc und da oben fünf externe festplatten größen
drauf stellt macht wahrscheinlich von der größe jetzt auch nicht auch nicht so
fett wenn du so aber wenn du darauf ein bisschen rumspielen willst ja ich sehe
es ja gerade schreibst du willst bisschen proxmox installieren und so
was ja da ist das sicherlich nicht verkehrt was kostet sowas aktuell gerade
Ich guck mir das grad mal an.
Willst du die holen bei Ebay oder wo?
Hier, bei rammkönig.de
Hat denn der Rammkönig
auch günstiges RAM? Hab ich noch nie gehört, Alter.
Rammkönig.
Was kostet
beim Rammkönig denn der RAM?
Hardware und Zubehör.
Wo gibt's denn hier RAM beim Rammkönig?
PC-Komponenten.
So super versteckt.
PC-Speicher.
Hersteller.
DDR4 und DDR3 hat der RAM-König.
Also ich hätte vom RAM-König eigentlich erwartet, dass der ein bisschen mehr hat als alten 8GB RAM.
Also was kostet so ein Mini-PC 219 Euro?
Hat, lass mal kurz gucken.
8GB RAM.
ehrlich gesagt 8 gig RAM ist zum einfachen bisschen rumspielen okay ja du kannst damit
jetzt nicht super viel machen aber zum rumspielen und 3 4 vms die nicht viel brauchen laufen lassen
reicht 8 gig wenn du glück hast hat es aber noch eine erweiterbarkeit für den zweiten slot das
weiß ich jetzt nicht ob man das hier erkennt oder ist er aufgelötet der RAM ne das ist die cpu
keine ahnung wo der ram ist vielleicht hast du ja glück und kannst noch einen zweiten
riegel rein machen also cpu technisch würde ich sagen guck mal das ist nur noch 8000 und
wenn du willst mit 8000 das ist auch der falsche du willst mit 8700 haben ja aber amazon genau
Ja.
Mal kurz.
Oh, mein Auge, Alter, mein Auge, Leute.
Ich muss es wieder einschalten.
Ja.
Also 8700K mehr als ausreichend für alle deine Experimente.
Ja, das ist ein halbwegs schneller Sechskernprozessor.
der ist okay der ist zwar acht jahre alt oder so aber vollkommen fein dass
älter als acht jahres zehn jahre alt oder so aber der ist vollkommen
vollkommen fein
ja wer will darauf auf windows 11 installieren keck wie aber steht hier
nicht steht hier nicht dabei und wann die sind bei intel immer date hier 2017
ja ok zehn jahre sauer war zehn acht jahren mit acht jahren gar nicht
verkehrt die grafikkarte ist natürlich schrott damit kann sogar nichts anfangen
also falls du irgendwie hoffst da halbwegs schnell irgendwelche models
drauf laufen lassen zu können kannst vergessen
also für ki ist dieser pc gar nichts nur so falls du das vorhattest ansonsten
aber wenn du doch home lab mäßig ein bisschen rum basteln willst ja wie du
gesagt hast wenn du ein bisschen
rox mox wo hat das war das geschrieben eben irgendwo das noch hier geschrieben
Proxmox rumspielen, ja.
Wenn du da ein bisschen mit Proxmox drauf rumbasteln willst,
ist es vollkommen okay.
Kann man sich gönnen.
Sehe ich keine Probleme mit.
Kannst dir alles Mögliche mal ein bisschen drauf ausprobieren.
Kannst dir Proxmox installieren, kannst dir Unraid drauf installieren.
Gucken, was dir da besser gefällt.
Wobei als Hauptsächlich Virtualisierungsplattform
ist Roxbox natürlich da schon
weiter vorne.
Ja. Also ich sehe
nichts, was dagegen sprechen würde.
Ich benutze KI. Okay, ich kann mal
beispielsweise ein Beispiel
sagen, am Freitag,
wofür ich KI benutzt habe.
So.
Wenn ihr in der Google Cloud
Festplatten habt oder Disks habt,
muss man ja sagen. Ja, ihr habt in der Google Cloud
Da kommt es manchmal vor, dass jemand von den Leuten, die für die Anwendung zuständig sind, die auf eurer Infrastruktur läuft, die kommen manchmal zu euch und sagen, Max, ich will jetzt in Produktion ein Deployment machen, kannst du mir mal einen Snapshot von der Disk ziehen?
und bisher bin ich dann immer ins
Webinterface gegangen, hab
die Discs rausgesucht,
die er meint, das ist ja nicht unbedingt
immer klar, was er meint,
weil die Discs
heißen ja teilweise super kryptisch,
such die richtige Disc aus,
klickt auf die drei Punkte drauf, sagt Snapshot,
hakt die richtigen Sachen an,
und dann kreiert er Snapshot.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, ey, warum brauchst du
denn nicht einfach mal ein Skript dafür
zum Snapshots ziehen?
Und da habe ich ein bisschen mit KI rumgespielt. Ich mache das meistens so. Ich baue das Skript ganz rudimentär so in die Richtung, wie es sein soll.
Ja, ich habe beispielsweise mit FZF eine Projektauswahl am Anfang von Hand gebaut, so nach dem Motto, in welchem Projekt möchten Sie eine Festplatte snapshotten oder klonen.
Dann habe ich nach FZF gepiped, du hattest dann die Auswahl, dieses Projekt, dieses Projekt, dieses Projekt, dieses Projekt, konntest du dann fasi-searchen mit FZF.
So, und dann habe ich das soweit gemacht.
Und dann habe ich drunter geschrieben, einfach Kommentar, ähm, ja, Kommentar, drunter, drunter geschrieben, ähm, so nach dem Motto, implement with gcloud, äh, bla bla bla, so.
Und was habe ich dann der KI reinkopypastet und habe die mal einen Vorschlag schicken lassen, wie man denn jetzt ab da das machen könnte, das eigentliche Klonen bzw. Snapshotten der Disk.
und ich muss sagen,
Opus 5 hat geregelt.
Mit weiteren FZF-Abfragen,
mit Abfragen, was man für einen Snapshot-Typ haben will,
was man eigentlich genau machen will, hat geregelt.
Ich habe da noch ein bisschen dran rumeditiert danach.
Ich habe danach noch beispielsweise die Fehlermeldung,
die es aus irgendwelchen Gründen auf Deutsch gemacht hat,
auf Englisch geschrieben, noch ein paar Sachen rausgeschmissen,
noch ein bisschen was editiert.
Aber ich hatte so in ungefähr zwei Stunden
ein fix und fertiges Skript
zum
Disk-Snapshotten.
Inklusive einer sinnvollen Auswahl.
Ja, also das zeigt mir, dass ich kann
das Projekt auswählen, ich kann auswählen,
die Disk ist für diesen Kubernetes-Cluster, willst du den haben
dafür und diesen Labels. Ist eigentlich
ganz nice. Ja, also für sowas
ist KI echt nett verkehrt.
Man sollte halt nicht das Ding
Copy-Pasten und
einfach mal direkt gegen Brot ausführen.
Das ist vielleicht nicht so schlau. Aber für solche
Sachen. Ist KI echt nicht
verkehrt? Echt okay.
Ja,
für Log-Auswertung finde ich KI auch richtig
gut.
Copy-Paste-Fehlermeldung in KI
und sag mal, ey, was
stimmt da nicht? Das ist auch sinnvoll.
Wofür es auch, also was KI auch
echt ganz gut kann, ist
hier, ich habe hier ein Kubernetes-Yaml-File
und ich habe hier irgendwo
einen Fehler drin. Guck mal.
Und dann sagt er, ja, hier, die Sache
muss eigentlich an der Stelle da drunter
eingerückt sein. Also
KI ist, also man
ist auf jeden Fall, also insofern gehe ich da
schon mit, was der Nvidia-Typ
gesagt hat, man ist
auf jeden Fall als Engineer
viel effektiver mit
KI. Was ich
aber nicht sehe ist, dass KI
jetzt irgendwie in nächster Zeit die ganzen
Engineers replacen wird.
Ob
das natürlich in dem Ausmaß stimmt,
Und was der Nvidia-Chef da sagt, da kann man sich jetzt natürlich drüber streiten.
Ich meine, der hat natürlich eigenes Interesse dran, oh, huge follow,
hat natürlich eigenes Interesse dran, das Wissen zu verkaufen.
Also der Nvidia-Chef hat sinngemäß gesagt, wenn du einen XYZ-Engineer einstellst,
Software-Engineer einstellst, DevOps-Engineer einstellst, egal,
wenn du irgendjemanden einstellst für 150.000 Euro im Jahr
und der nicht mindestens nochmal das Gleiche in Tokens ausgibt, ist es schlecht.
Sagt der Nvidia-Chef.
Ja klar, der sagt ja auch, Tokens sind Profit, Leute.
Dass der Nvidia-Chef das sagt, ist irgendwo logisch.
Also so weit würde ich nicht unbedingt gehen,
aber du bist auf jeden Fall deutlich effektiver mit KI-Unterstützung als alles von Hand zu machen.
wie kommst du darauf dass die kein tpm haben weil sie habe ich das habe ich
nicht gesagt dass die kein tpm haben
das hat der chat gesagt ich habe das einfach noch vorgelesen was der chat
gesagt hat keine ahnung ob die tpm haben oder nicht wird mich aber persönlich
auch nicht großartig jungen wenn ich habe auch drauf installieren will und
das ja auch das ziel
So, wir sind richtig krass gesitetrackt.
Ich wollte eigentlich GH-Crap ausprobieren.
So, wie funktioniert das hier?
GH-Crap.
Quickstart.
Okay, GH-Crap.
Or if you already have a link, just paste it in.
GH-Crap und jetzt Rustlang?
Wow, jetzt wird es aber fancy, Alter.
Äh.
Okay.
Okay, Chat.
Was bin ich sehend?
Ich sehe das Git-Repo hier drinnen.
Okay.
Ja.
Okay, read me, MD.
Bam.
Okay, da kann man ein Häkchen dran machen.
Und jetzt?
Enter, open.
Open?
Also, end...
Verzeichnisse kann man nur enden.
What the hell?
Okay, was passiert, wenn man GH-Crap normal startet?
Man kann suchen.
Na, da kommt mal ein Upsnap.
Max, hieß das Ding nicht so?
Das ist es doch.
Oder wir können auch mal, Leute, wir suchen mal nach dem
der Fiat Champ.
Es gibt ein Repro-Fiat Champ Beta?
Äh, wann hab ich das angelegt?
Okay, Repo von mir.
Zeig mal her.
Aber, aber, aber.
Also, okay, okay.
Aber, was ist
daran jetzt besser?
Als im Browser
drauf zu gehen?
Review.
Ah, man kann
Dateien sich angucken.
Aber das kann ich im Browser auch.
Ach, man kann sich
Dateien downloaden.
Okay, das ist in der Tat ganz nützlich.
Aber da hat sich das gar nicht runtergeladen.
Guck mal, ich hab Geocrap gesagt.
Geochamp.
Zack.
Jetzt hab ich die Readme angehackt und gesagt Download.
Ach, der downloadet das in den Download-Ordner, nicht in dem aktuellen Verzeichnis, wo ich drinnen bin.
Das ist ja dumm.
Ja, okay.
Ähm.
Chat, was sagen wir zu dem Tool?
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Ich wüsste ernsthaft nicht, wann ich das verwenden würde.
also die 1 ok ok doch doch doch ich weiß eine sache wofür ich verwenden würde nämlich genau
für das was ich eben gesagt habe ich bin im browser unterwegs und will diese datei
runterladen mal gucken ob es das kann oder hat es jetzt runtergeladen
das ist jetzt runtergeladen
das kann es nicht das ist jetzt irgendwie
einstellen kann man bestimmt also also für den einzigen fall wo ich es jetzt für benutzen würde
geht das nicht guck mal vielleicht vielleicht sollten wir uns mal die option hätte das hat
es eine man page natürlich nicht so ob nicht mehr im trend guck mal help an was haben wir
denn hier alles hält sich sehr in grenzen download files zu können direkt okay schon mal hat verkehrt
Geht
Mehr hat das nicht
Also heißt im Endeffekt
Okay, das geht nicht
Das finde ich doof, das finde ich echt doof
Weil dafür wäre das wirklich ganz praktisch
Weil wie gesagt, wenn du so Sachen
Weh gettest
Wenn du so Sachen weh gettest
Dann lädt er immer die Datei runter
Das ist halt doof
Ich meine, man kann sich das
Theoretisch kann man sich das auch easy scripten
Man könnte sagen, okay
Man macht sich eine Function
Sowas wie
GitHub Download
Oder GW Get oder sowas
Und du search and replace einfach
die URL. Das ist ja relativ predictable
hier, wie das funktioniert.
Also da könnte man sich
Functionware
Für sowas ist KI zum Beispiel ganz praktisch.
Sowas müsste sogar
kostenloses Chat-GPT hinkriegen.
Fragen wir mal.
Ich lade öfters
Sachen von GitHub runter.
Zum Beispiel.
Der lädt aber immer
direkt HTML runter, nicht die Datei.
Ich brauche
einen Bash
alias oder Function
die dann
die Datei
runter lädt,
nicht das HTML.
Mal gucken, ob FreeJetGPT
da was auf die Reihe
kriegt.
Ja.
Was macht's?
Das macht einen Check.
Äh.
Ja, macht einen Check.
Local Raw.
Ja.
Raw.
Also richtig geil lesbar ist es jetzt nicht.
Aber das macht nichts.
Äh, Raw.
Das ist jetzt Bash Magic.
Der ersetzt
Blob.
Der ersetzt Blob
durch
Okay, Leute. Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was das macht.
Vielleicht erklärt uns das Chat-GPT sogar.
Erkläre mir das.
Erklär mal.
Ja, das weiß ich alles.
Was?
Was macht...
Ja, ja, ja, das ist alles klar.
Alles klar, alles klar.
Alles klar.
Was ist das?
Das sieht erstmal ziemlich hässlich aus.
Ja.
Variable Search Replace ist das.
Er gibt Hallo Bash.
Also, in dieser...
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich das.
In dieser Variable...
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Ich glaube, ich verstehe es.
Also, in der Variable Raw
sucht er Slash Plop.
Was aber Blödsinn ist,
Weil Blob überhaupt nicht in Raw drin steht, oder?
Oder bin ich blöd?
Kann das sein, dass ChatGPT dumm Scheiß hier gebaut hat?
Fragezeichen.
Der soll in Raw Blob ersetzen.
Da ist überhaupt kein Blob drin.
Wollen wir es mal ausprobieren?
Ich meine, viel kaputt gehen kann damit nichts.
WTF?
Was? Warum hat das jetzt das komplette Ding kopiert?
Okay, GH Raw.
Und zwar
das da.
Ja.
Okay, ich hab gesagt,
sogar, es ist so einfach,
das müsste sogar dummes, kostenloses
Chat-GPT hinkriegen.
Aber anscheinend
wird Chat-GPT wirklich immer
beschissener. Wirklich immer.
Weißt du was? Wir lassen das mal.
Wir lassen uns mal die China-Chinesen-KI,
kostenlose China-Chinesen-KI machen.
Mal gucken, ob die besser ist.
Gucken, ob die besser ist.
Wir machen das mal...
Ich hab grad nicht mein Login.
Okay, das sieht doch schon...
WTF?
Warum macht die genau den gleichen Scheiß?
Welche Daten? Welche Daten hat denn da trainiert, Alter?
Okay, wir testen es auch nochmal.
Okay, wir geben ihm
nochmal eine Chance, okay?
Und ChatGPT,
ChatGPT geben wir auch nochmal eine Chance.
Der sagt, der antwortet.
Ah, jetzt ist der Fehler klar.
Ich werde dir ganz ehrlich sagen,
wo die Probleme liegen.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Ja, mein Fehler.
Ich habe beim Escaping
tatsächlich einen Fehler gemacht.
Das Problem hier ist,
in dem sieht man, was passiert.
Korrigierte Version.
Da steht immer noch kein Plop drinne.
Da steht immer noch kein Plop drinne,
was er Search & Replace kann.
Ach doch, hier steht er.
Hier steht der Plop drin.
Okay, ich bin dumm.
Ich bin dumm.
Die KI ist gar nicht so falsch.
Hier steht Plop drin. Ach, jetzt verstehe ich das.
Okay, korrigiert.
Dann nimm diese Funktion.
Okay.
Bam.
Jetzt nochmal Guitar Brawl.
Ah.
Leute, das hätte ich jetzt
aber schneller, das hätte ich jetzt aber
wahrscheinlich schneller selbst gemacht.
Frag Gemini Free.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, also wir geben dem immer noch eine extra Chance.
Das sieht nach einem
Kopierfehler aus.
Hab ich hier Mist kopiert?
Ne, hab ich nicht.
Ich hab hier nichts falsch copy-pasted.
Hier nochmal die Funktion.
Diesmal robuster geschrieben.
Kein doppelten Slashes in der Ersetzung.
Explicit der Datei.
Okay, GHDL
Die ist so kaputt, dass sie sich nicht mal
mehr einfügen lässt, den Bash
WTF, okay
Versagt, versagt
Abgekackt, würde ich sagen
Ja, Kimmy muss man sich leider einloggen
Also, Gemini Free
Hat das ein Chat, ohne dass man sich einloggen muss?
Okay.
Wo ist mein Text?
Äh.
Wo ist mein Text hin?
Warum ist der Text nicht im...
Ah, hier da.
Flashlight?
Was hat man hier?
Ich kann nur Flashlight machen.
Das Problem liegt da...
Ja, das ist mir egal. Okay.
Geh, Hangeart. Zeig mal mal.
Macht das mehr Sinn, was Gemini hier bastelt?
Ja, das ist okay.
Raw Uhr 1.
Okay, da geht direkt auf das erste
GitHub.com wird
replaced durch Raw
Das könnte noch stimmen
Und dann mit Raw URL wird Plop durch
irgendwas anderes replaced
Schauen wir mal, ob das Gemini gut hinkriegt
Okay
GH
Was haben wir jetzt? GH Get?
Gemini
Der hat nicht richtig
Escaped
Ja, weil die richtige
URL ist
RawGitterBadam
Da, da
Das hier fehlt, RevsHead und so
Also, alle kostenlose KIs zu dumm.
Alle zu dumm.
Letztendlich von der Idee her ist es doch eigentlich gar nicht so kompliziert, sowas zu programmieren.
Also, man nimmt diese URL, man cuttet sich den Part hier raus.
Den Part cuttet man sich raus.
den setzt man dann hier ein, an dieser URL,
zack, den setzt man hier ein,
Revs Headmaster kann man lassen,
und dann cuttet man sich die Readme raus.
Na gut, aber, ha,
nee, ganz so einfach ist es tatsächlich nicht,
ganz so einfach ist es nicht, weil der Fahrt
könnte ja länger sein, ja, also man cuttet sich
quasi alles nach Main raus und hängt es hinten an.
Ah, das könnte man machen.
Man kann hier sicherlich
Search and Replace Magic machen,
ah, das könnte man,
bestimmt irgendwie könnte man da
search and replace magic machen.
Wollen wir mal probieren.
Also man könnte hier bestimmt
sagen, wir ersetzen
github.com
durch
raw github content.
Äh.
Achso.
Den Punkt
muss ich ja scapen, oder?
Äh.
Chat. Warum bin ich zu
Ach!
Weil da Slashes drin sind, oder?
Hä?
Sag mal.
Was ist denn jetzt das Problem?
Kann ich kein Seed mehr machen, oder was?
Dazu Pepega für einen Seed zu machen.
Ach, es habe ich vergessen.
Alter.
Oh Mann.
Ja.
Gut.
Okay.
So, zack.
Guck, jetzt haben wir das hier vorne
hinten.
So, jetzt müssen wir Blob
replacen durch
Revs
Revs Head.
Oder
machen wir mal
So, wir replacen
Okay, da müssen wir jetzt
andere Scores verwenden. Wir replacen
Plop
durch
Rev's Head.
Nicht Plop, Plop.
So, und wenn ich jetzt richtig liege, kann ich das
downloaden, oder?
Easy.
Nee.
So.
Ja, das war's.
Also,
das ist alles, was man machen muss im Endeffekt.
Das hier.
Also die KI hat schon ein bisschen
verkackt in dem Fall, würde ich sagen.
Wisst ihr was? Ich finde das aber gut.
Ich finde das
aber tatsächlich nicht schlecht.
Ich
mache mir das mal in
meine
Ich nehme eine Basher C.
Also, erst einmal, wir nehmen das hier.
Wir nehmen das hier, was die KI erzeugt hat,
weil davon finde ich
alles kacke, außer
das hier.
BH Get.
Bla bla bla.
So, reicht.
usage
und jetzt hier unten drunter
machen wir mal ein seed
und dann haben wir eine function
eine bash function
die das macht
echo
dollar i
gepiped nach seed
und dann das Ganze W-Getten.
Und jetzt sollte das funktionieren.
Probieren wir das mal aus.
Probieren wir mal aus hier.
Zack.
Ich hoffe, ich habe nichts falsch gemacht.
GH-Get.
Bam.
Readme.md. Hat funktioniert.
Easy. Also Leute, ich glaube,
wir waren jetzt nicht viel langsamer als mit KI, oder?
wobei wir ein bisschen uns freuen.
Das finde ich immer die beste Kombination.
So quasi in Kombination mit KI das machen.
Weil dieses Gedöns hier kann KI...
Aber ich habe keine Ahnung, was die KI da rumgemacht hat.
Das wäre relativ easy gewesen.
So.
Zack.
Next.
Eigentlich waren wir dabei, ein Video zu gucken,
was es für geile Command Line Tools gibt.
Also, GH-Crap war jetzt nicht so toll.
Das können wir...
Auch der Escape-Bug.
Ja, Escaping in Bash ist auch wirklich echt ziemlich eklig.
GH-Crap.
Uninstallen wir.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Hat mich doch nicht so begeistert jetzt.
Next.
Was haben wir als nächstes hier?
How it works.
Round.
Nee, nee, das brauche ich.
Was haben wir als nächstes?
Air Sync Maxing.
Was zum Teufel soll das sein?
So inspect the repo, find what matters and take only that.
I think you get the idea now.
Ja.
Ja, niemand kann sich die Option von Airsoak richtig merken.
Was ist eigentlich Q-Man?
Was benutzen die Leute?
Die coolen Leute anstatt Man-Pages?
Q-Man.
A more modern Man-Page-Viewer.
Okay, das ist auch jemand in dem Video, der wirklich alle Tools durch irgendwas ersetzen muss.
Source.
Written in C.
Oho.
Okay, das ist more modern.
Weil es verschiedene Sections hat.
Und du hast ein bisschen...
Das finde ich in der Tat gar nicht so verkehrt.
Gibt es leider nur als Our Package.
Ja, Bat ist auch so ein Ding.
Kann Batman Pages highlighten?
Wirklich, wirklich gut.
Sieht das jetzt nett aus, oder?
oder?
Kannst du bedenkenlos aus dem Hour installieren?
Ja, ich versuche nur möglichst wenig
Hour-Packages zu haben.
Wieso ist das von dir? Ist das dein Project?
Also das sieht so nicht gut aus.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass die normale Man-Pages
jetzt irgendwie super schlecht werden.
Kann ein normales Man-Page
eine Color-Variante
haben?
Was muss man konfigurieren?
Habiger Pager.
How to colorize manpages.
How to dis...
Oh, da gibt es schon 17, Alter.
Boah.
Was muss man dafür machen jetzt?
Most.
Nee.
Most will ich nicht. Was ist denn Most jetzt schon wieder?
Eine andere Less-Alternative oder was?
Nee, das wollen wir nicht.
Dat wollen wir nicht stellen.
Erstmal, erstmal machen wir hier
KI-Stells.
Okay, und jetzt?
Nein, nein.
Ja, wirklich viel schöner ist es
jetzt auch nicht.
Aha.
Bad as Export Man Page
Okay.
Schick.
Das gefällt mir.
Das setze ich mir als Default-Kommando.
Ich mag nämlich Sachen,
die genauso funktionieren wie auf Servern,
aber halt lokal vielleicht ein bisschen enhanced sind.
Das ist gut.
Ich will nämlich gar kein anderes Manpage-Kommando verwenden, ehrlich gesagt.
Weil ich will mich ja nicht daran gewöhnen
und dann will ich auf dem Server ein Manpage aufmachen
und schreibe Qman oder so.
Selbst wenn du nicht Ali hast, sind die Optionen anders.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Gut, klicken und so, das kann man jetzt hier natürlich nicht.
Verschiedene Sections kann man auch nicht.
Das finde ich aber echt ganz cool.
das werde ich mir mal hier
Export
Hä? Warum hat er das nicht copy pasted?
Packen wir das mal hier
Ey, die ist so
eklig, undurchsichtig
meine
RC
Wo habe ich denn hier die Sache?
Ach, da ist der ganze Krampl, okay
Ich mache das anscheinend ganz unten, auch okay
Exportman Pager
Ja nice
Heißt im Endeffekt
Wenn ich jetzt neue Shell starte
Habe ich das jetzt immer defaultmäßig
Sehr gut, gefällt mir
Hat was
Das wird nie refactored
Das ist write only
Okay
R-Sync-Maxing kommt jetzt
Das sieht mir schon wieder zu krass abgedreht aus, ey.
Das ist nichts für mich.
Außerdem, er synke ich, wenn schon auf irgendwelchen Servern und nicht bei mir lokal, da bringt mir das nichts.
Ne, ne, ne, das ist...
Das brauchen wir nicht. Was haben wir hier sonst noch zu bieten?
Brauche ich auch nicht.
Brauchst du nicht.
Aber kann das sein, dass das alles written in Rust ist, was er hier zeigt?
Bei Laserspeedfast.
Äh, also.
Ja.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
So, was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
Keck W.
Sehr gut.
Guter Name.
Okay, Q, nicht Keck W.
Ach ja.
Algorithm deciding. Kann es YouTube
Sachen abspielen?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
What you should listen to. Privacy
is something they care about as well. I mean
it's a local music player, so that's what you
would expect. And most...
Kev.
Music for the shell.
Okay, ich will mal was ausprobieren. Ob das Ding...
Aber das Ding theoretisch...
YouTube Videos abspielen könnte.
Hallo.
Kev?
Äh.
Nein.
Nein, nein.
WTF minus minus
hält, macht die Manpage auf.
Was, minus W?
Minus W gibt es doch überhaupt nicht.
Ach, minus
keck W. Ah, jetzt habe ich es getaggt. Ich war zu dumm
dafür, oder? Hängen geblieben.
Okay, nee, das funktioniert nicht.
Keck W
examples.
Achso, okay, brauchen wir nicht.
Unsinnig.
Zack. Recursive.
Weg damit.
Was? Ah, nicht keck.
Kev.
Er ist local. Naja.
Brauch ich nicht. Ich hab keine Musik mehr lokal.
Zack. Bam.
Keines der Tools dabei, wo ich sagen würde,
braucht man unbedingt.
Aber es hat mich immerhin mal auf eine gute Idee gebracht,
diesen GitHub
Download Alias
da einzubauen.
weil das weil das mache ich echt oft hier so sachen wie ich will mir ich
sowieso keine ahnung ich bin dann in einem github repo und sagt mir okay
example whatever das da ich will mir ich will mir das darunter laden oder ich
will mir das darunter laden so docker file das will ich haben und mit wg hat
geht es immer nicht wenn ich jetzt github get mache ach so hat sich die
stellen dann auf ja wenn ich jetzt sagen hier gh get, gh get, bam, zack, dockerfile das ist ganz praktisch
nutzt du lazy git? nein ich nutze nur git per cli beste alles andere suckt github command line
einzig sinnvolle aber was haben wir sonst noch hier ich habe das etliche
die prominent glasfaserausbau darum sind 5g lte und starling keine alternativen ich würde
mal sagen. Zwei Sachen, die mir sofort
einfällen. Die sind deutlich störungsanfälliger.
Latency ist ein Problem.
Und Shared Medium.
Okay, Starlink.
Starlink nicht
wirklich Shared Medium, oder?
Oder?
Nee, gell?
Glaub nicht.
Wollen hast du dir schon den fancy task manager vom ehemaligen ms entwickler
angeguckt ich kenne ich kenne ihnen die videos von dem typ aber er hat ja schon
gefühlte erzählt er erzählt ja gefühlt in jedem in jedem zweiten video dass der
task manager programmiert hat was aber komisch ist weil irgendwie ist er nirgendwo
erwähnt.
Genau, der Dude hier.
Download free for Linux.
Nein.
Nein. Aber wenn das
mit Linux geritten ist, ja, wenn
das mit Linux programmiert ist,
dann würde mich
interessieren,
das ist doch bestimmt,
das ist doch bestimmt
eine Elektron-Anwendung
oder sowas.
Gibt es da den Source-Code irgendwo?
Oder ist das Closed-Source-Microsoft-App-Image?
Task-Manager-OG.
Wir gucken mal da rein.
Okay, also das ist typisch Microsoft.
Das ist schon mal nicht Open-Source.
Also wir downloaden das mal.
Wir führen es aber nicht aus.
wir extrakten das gucken da mal rein was der sache ist das ist schon mal fett das
ist bestimmt elektron anwendung
image
so
image extract wie ging das
AppImageExtract, genau.
Kann man das nicht anders?
Extract AppImage without running it.
das irgendwo ansquash fs genau das suche ich ansquash fs
was muss ich dafür installieren squash fs oder so
squash fuße squash fs tools das soll man sich installieren
Okay
Task Manager
Okay, anscheinend geht das so nicht
Ich will das nicht run
Ah ja, minus minus extract
Das will ich ja nicht
Ich will das nicht ausführen
ok feier oder kann das okay sie dann immer feier oder feier oder
weil ein rohler
kunder umgeheilt
damit nicht funktionieren
wie kann man den scheiß extrakt nicht will das nicht ausführen
in seven zipp umbenennen wirklich das geht
Ne.
Immer das Extract.
Okay, ich habe legit keinen Plan.
Ich will das auch nicht ausführen.
Habe ich das jetzt schon ein bisschen
wurmt?
Unsquash FS.
App Image Offset.
Und wo kommt AppImageOffset her?
Wow.
Okay, okay.
Anscheinend Bash gedöhnt.
Ach so.
Ah, okay, okay.
task manager app image und das kann ich copy pasten
anfälle
also das funst das funst das funst
App-Image-Offset
uns nicht. Warum?
Was ist falsch?
Äh, irgendwie Mist mitkopiert?
Was ist was falsch? Seht ihr das irgendwo?
Du hast den ersten Buchstaben
nicht mitkopiert?
Hä? Doch.
Hab ich doch.
Welche Buchstaben denn nicht?
Bei der ersten Zeile.
Ah.
Okay.
Ich habe nichts gesagt. Ihr habt recht.
Chat.
Aber es ist immer noch Bad Expression.
Warum ist das so kompliziert,
so ein fucking App-Image zu extrakten?
Und warum kann er nicht den Source-Code einfach irgendwo bereitstellen?
Hä?
Warum sind die leer?
Warum ist das leer?
Ah, Start of Section Headers gibt es nicht.
Doch, gibt es.
Hä?
Ja, noch ein anderer hat was geschrieben.
Machen wir einfach mal das, was der hier schreibt.
AWK Magic.
Okay.
Exzellent funktioniert.
Und jetzt?
Okay, weißt du was?
Scheiß drauf, wir machen es einfach in der 4M, easy
Machen sie in der 4M
Und dann ist es egal
Upt, Install,
Weget.
Upt, Update. Wir machen es, wir machen es in der VRM.
Temp.
Er weiß ja nicht, was da drin ist.
Ich glaube nicht, dass da irgendwas drin ist.
Aber es sieht immer doof aus.
Okay, weh jetzt.
Zack.
Da ist es.
So, und jetzt...
...kann man das nämlich extracten.
Haha.
Was zur Hölle?
Extract?
Wie war das jetzt?
Vielleicht kann man das so angeben.
Es ist gar nicht so einfach da an den Source Code, beziehungsweise an die Sachen, die da drin sind, dranzukommen.
Ähm.
Extract?
Ja.
Minus Minus Extract.
Okay, jetzt hat er es extracted.
Ja, SquashFS gut.
Was ist da drin?
App?
Oder wo ist denn hier was?
Tree?
Pick Waffs.
So, wo haben wir denn jetzt was?
Brauchen wir alles nett?
Okay, da ist irgendwelches Binary-Zeug drin.
Also, der malt die Sachen selbst mit OpenGL.
Aber das ist bestimmt Vibe-Coded, hä?
Das Ding ist bestimmt Hardcore-Vibe-Coded.
weil sowas machst du nicht einfach mal so mit opengl alles selber rendern
qt conf okay bin niveau wo lag das drin
user bin
ok
das ist auf cute basis
Ja, das ist garanti- vibecoded.
Ah, ein paar Tokens verbraten.
Ah ja.
Und der Southcode war wahrscheinlich so schlimm, dass er es nicht veröffentlichen wollte.
es hat im krankenhaus warte zimmer vom krankenhaus na dann kommen wir das dann
aber wirklich veröffentlicht für die gesamte wieder warum nicht
im moment ich habe hier youtube tabs auf ich habe youtube tabs auf und so habe ich auch
noch ein paar tabs also aber ich muss ja mein ramm irgendwie voll kriegen also ich tippe mal
drauf wie gesagt es ist störanfälliger shared medium und solche geschichten ist
das problem latency schwankende bandbreite das dürfte so das dürfte so
dass das problem sein da heute ich muss mal kurz gucken was macht die mikrowelle
ich krieg langsam echt richtig brutal hunger
Oh.
Ich glaube, die Mikrowelle ist an.
Mein Home Assistant
lädt gerade nicht richtig.
Oh, Mikrowelle ist an, Leute.
Was gibt es heute zu futtern?
Nudel
mit veganer
Bolognese. Also im Prinzip
ganz normale Tomatensauce und veganem
Hackfleisch.
Eure übertriebenen Smart Homes, das gucke ich immer gern.
Das gucke ich immer gerne.
Aber das kann ich jetzt nicht gucken.
Das ist das Dashboard von deiner Eiswürfelmaschine.
Denn Wasser ist ja häufiger gefiltert als ein guter Watt.
Bei den Erdbeeren hört der Spaß auf.
Das gucken wir das nächste Mal.
Das gucke ich immer gerne.
Was die Leute sich da so heimzurecht basteln.
Ich gehe jetzt auf und chat.
Ich weiß, ich habe es das letzte Mal schon gesagt.
Wir machen heute Rust.
Vielleicht machen wir heute Rustim-Stream.
Oder aber
wir könnten uns auch mal
das da angucken.
Oder tatsächlich mal ein aktuelles Fedora ausprobieren.
Weil der Chat ja gesagt hat,
bisschen Distro-Hopping
wäre nicht verkehrt.
Schauen wir mal.
Wir sehen uns, Chat. Bis dann.
Macht's gut. See you.